looks like we have a number of absences
but we might as well go ahead and get
started is everybody ready
awesome
and just a reminder to the folks in the
audience if you'd like to speak on a
bill please fill out one of these pink
okay we will now open the public hearing
on House Bill 15 relative to the rate of
the business Enterprise tax and for the
record I have a conflict because I pay
this tax but I will participate so with
that we will recognize representative
Janine notter who as Prime sponsor of
thank you good morning Madam chair and
members of the committee my name is
Janine nodder I represent the town of
Merrimack Hillsborough District 12.
as some of you know I come from the same
town as our late speaker dick hinch
he was a committed legislator who
excelled at bringing people together to
pass policies that would help the lives
of everyday New Hampshire citizens
I learned a lot from speaker hinch
when I was new to these Halls he
instilled in me that the most important
thing that you have as a legislator is
your word
if you make a promise it's up to you to
do everything that you can to keep it
that's why he was so committed to
keeping the promises of the business tax
relief that we made in the 2017 state
budget
if the timeline from that budget
remained intact the rates that are
included in House Bill 15 would already
be the law
along with our late speaker I felt that
we made a promise to New Hampshire's
business community in 2017. it's not too
late to keep that promise
House Bill 15 honors our word and gives
tax relief so that employers from the
local mom and pop corner store to Market
Basket can offer another teenager their
first job are companies like Fidelity in
my town can continue to bring more great
jobs across New England to its Merrimack
campus
passing this bill sends a strong message
to businesses across the region and
across the country that New Hampshire is
the right place to bring and grow a
company
most importantly though it is that this
bill would keep our word that we made in
2017.
that was critically important to speaker
hinch and should be important to all of
us for these reasons I encourage the
committee to find this bill ought to
would you be open to questions
well I'm late for my own committee so um
would you mind if I referred the
question to other people
okay
okay I will recognize Mr Greg Moore from
Americans for Prosperity New Hampshire
I hope everybody enjoyed their snow day
yesterday uh
Madam chair members of the committee
thank you for the opportunity to speak
here today for the record my name is
Craig Moore I am the state director with
Americans for Prosperity here in New
Hampshire
and I've been in this role now 10 years
and for 10 years we've been having
discussions about business taxes and
business tax rates and one of the things
that I found is sort of a durable
narrative is it is it is devolved in
many cases to almost like
World War one trench warfare where one
side argues for economic growth the
other Assad argues for Revenue
maximization
and uh well I think well I think we've
seen uh the benefits of the tax release
we've we've achieved over the Arc of the
last eight years now since starting with
the first uh First Tax release was
passed in the 2015 budget or I guess
eventually what became the 2015 budget
and so I said how how do we sort of
break through that narrative how do you
shift the focus and try to try to put
some uh color to the words that you're
talking about when you're discussing uh
the components of of uh the business
taxes and and its impact on the state
so what I did is I went to Fred no no
not the clerk uh Fred is a Federal
Reserve economic data which is a
byproduct of the sorry sorry
representative uh
it's a it's a byproduct of the Federal
Reserve of uh of St Louis and it's a
great Warehouse of data
and so what I did is I said okay we
started this tax relief in 2015. we made
the argument that it was going to
provide going to provide economic growth
and this was going to be a pro-growth
policy so let's see how that's worked
out
so if you look at this the uh the second
column the GDP from 2015 to 2021 growth
uh that's on the percentage basis based
on the uh on the Fred data
and I said okay well if that's the case
let's look at the that's six years worth
of data uh 2022 by the way 2022 data is
not available yet uh Department of
Commerce won't put that out until March
so we won't have 2022 state level data
until until for several months so we
looked at him we said okay
six years that's what it's done so I
said okay let's reference into the prior
six years how did we what's changed over
the Arc of those six years and that's
the first column
and I think you'll notice that there's
been a substantial amount of growth in
our in our economy in over the Arc of
the last six years
and I'll note that similar to New
Hampshire in 2015 Maine actually passed
a major tax reform
unlike New Hampshire it wasn't tax
relief it was tax reform
with where they lowered their individual
and corporate rates and then raise their
sales tax so they offset
they offset the reductions and shifted
it over to the sales tax so I think
you'll notice that those two states that
made those major tax
changes are the two states that have
seen Far and Away the greatest economic
growth in the region
and when you look at the region what
you'll see is Massachusetts seems to be
pegged pretty close closely to Nash to
National growth I think that's pretty
consistent by the way the national one I
as a just as a data Proviso
uh National Data is done on a quarterly
basis so the national isn't exactly
Apples to Apples so I just picked a
reference point of Q4 the relative years
as opposed to going uh Fred just offers
annual data for the states they offer
quarterly data for for the national so
that's that's one one point of the data
but I think that that it tells a
compelling story and I think it shows
how a state that was actually falling
behind the national growth Trends has
actually pulled well ahead of national
growth Trends and that to me is is a
symbol of of prosperity that's
ultimately what we're looking for in our
in our economy and in our society is
trying to how do we find ways to
increase prosperity
and when you look at a data like this it
gives it it paints a clearer picture
that shows that the the steps we're
taking are steps in the right direction
these are positive steps that are
improving the lives of granted stators
so we think that's an important thing to
continue we specifically think it's
important to continue in the business
Enterprise tax which
um I I could tell a long story but I'll
try to be very succinct about it in a
prior life I worked as a
corporate Communications company and
working with high techs and in greater
Boston area
and I had a company that moved from New
Hampshire to Massachusetts and I expect
I asked him I expected typically the
answer you get why companies move to
Massachusetts access to access to staff
and and they said tax reasons which was
just confusing to me and then they
explained the business Enterprise tax
and how
companies that are capital intensive
companies
are losing money uh startups that's a
bet that's what they're burning through
their capital and they're losing money
and they're still paying taxes so that
was that always uh struck a chord with
me and that's why I think that that this
reduction in the business Enterprise tax
is so critical because I think it's
important not just for small businesses
and in fact I I it's it's a case last
year when we had this this discussion I
know there was a legislation House Bill
1221 which produced both the BPT and the
BET and I remember having a conversation
with with the chair at the time and and
played with them and listen if you have
to pick one pick the bet not the BPT but
they went the other direction but we
think that this is critical to continue
our economic growth I we think that the
the revenue picture for the state since
the state started this uh business tax
regime change has has shown that that
we've seen significant surpluses in our
business tax lines and I think that the
the economic growth shows a compelling
story as to why we should continue it so
for that reason I encourage you to find
a spill out to pass I'd be happy to take
questions
thank you for your testimony uh other
hands up yes representative plett yes
thank you for taking my question uh Mr
Moore
um
you you're attributing apparently the
large growth in New Hampshire to the
reduction in business profit taxes
solely or is it there are other causes
possibly I I promise you that there are
that there is multi-factors involved
here I guarantee you that that there's a
lot more going on than than just
business taxes I'm sure I'm sure the the
fellows in the the second corner corner
office would take credit for a lot of
those but uh I would say I would say to
you that that when you look at this this
picture it paints a picture of a state
that's heading in the right direction is
seeing accelerating economic growth and
one and one that uh that is worth
continuing now
are there other factors of course or
other factors and and there's no way to
say this is inputs and outputs but I
will note that the two states that made
major what I would describe as
beneficial tax reforms are the two
states that are seeing the outliers in
terms of economic growth you just
representative almi then representative
there it goes
um
have you
looked at on these numbers going from on
[Music]
to 13 and 13 to or or even 15 and then
15 up on but looked at at
the scope across the years of what
happened in in
the in New England and in New Hampshire
we have always had a history of being
the last state in in the last state out
of the recession on and
09 is
actually oh mostly 08 Revenue
and
was just starting to go into a recession
on
but
we really
um you
it's very easy to just cherry pick
certain dates and come on is there a
question that's totally different from
uh the one that you just made and have
you looked at the other alternatives
uh excuse me representative I'm not
exactly sure I understand your question
when you say the Alternatives could you
please clarify if you
a few years earlier in each time's
growth or you looked at on
seven years starting early or seven
years and then uh if or if you just did
what is usually done which is to take a
chart a a chart and track across the
years
on in on New England versus New
Hampshire
the answer is yes because uh because I
if you go to the Fred charts it has
historical data going back about 30
years so you can't avoid looking at the
chart it's it's right there when you go
to the data source
and uh I'd encourage you to go take a
look at it because one of the things
that I found is is and this is GDP it's
not tax revenue and the two are not the
same and I'm not I'm not suggesting the
two are the same uh but it's a lot
smoother than I would have anticipated
and I'm sure the revenue cycle is very
different than
than the GDP cycle I'm not trying to
conflate the two here
um but I just want to say the argument
for people who've supported this is has
been about economic growth not
necessarily Revenue growth and and I and
I want to clarify that that I I made
that point clear at the very beginning
that's that's been sort of the the
dichotomy that we've had over the Arc of
representative Ames did you have a
question
you did not representative ulery
thank you madam chair appreciate it
thank you for taking my question Mr
Moore
um you're equating
um economic growth with prosperity and
with prosperity you're then equating
that with uh increased revenues and
presented a chart to show that
what happens in a recession though when
Prosperity goes down state revenues are
going to go down
if we reduce the
bet
would not then the state
lose money because we reduced this and
so so as someone who uh as as you know
has been through a down economic cycle
in a different role
we had to make some pretty significant
um
recalibrations I'll just I'll say it
yeah there's no question that that
there's a cyclicality to the economy and
and and
as a policy maker the question isn't do
we do we uh ignore the cyclicality
because the reality is is we can we can
prepare for that type of cyclicality
whether it's a rainy day fund uh
alternate Revenue sources that there's a
there are ways to harden uh and protect
the state's ability to pay its bills
during an economy and I know that that
again the governor likes to speak very
regularly about our rather flush rainy
day fund as it stands right now
um frankly frankly I think that probably
should do more there but but I know that
there are limits in state law as to what
you can do in that space uh I've
encouraged him that he should direct
more of the Surplus to that as opposed
to one-time spending but
I I don't always get what I want either
so
so the answer to the answer to your
question I think is is that is that yes
there are Revenue cycles that that
accompany economic cycles and but there
follow-up
you indicate there are ways to hedge
against them would reducing this tax
be one of those ways because it would
make the companies more resilient
um the more
more better or
more capable or of competing with other
um entities both within and without the
state and thus allowing them rather than
reducing the the amount of revenue
generated would actually be able to
either sustain or or maybe even in some
instances increase the amount of revenue
generated because they would be
funneling off less
per sale to an account is that is that
an analysis sure I certainly have having
a more competitive and heartier
employers definitely helps with dealing
with recessionary woes I definitely
think that that this tax in particular
suits that purpose more so than the BPT
simply because this this tax is you more
focused on actually New Hampshire small
businesses than the BPT so the bet I
think from that cyclicality standpoint
is probably a better tool to ensure
long-term stability in the among
employers
so I do have a question this time
good morning morning
could you provide us with the year by
year
GDP growth
from which this summary data was
extracted so that it would show
going back to
2001 let's say
uh before the 2008 start point of your
data and forward to as far as we can go
which I guess is not including 2022 as
you pointed out it's not available
um so we could see year by year the
growth and take whatever chunks of that
we think are relevant or how they relate
to other phenomena that are going on
around us and
draw conclusions if they're warranted
but at least be able to see the whole
whole picture that you were looking at
when you broke it down into these
basically two periods could you know
that sure and again the reason why I
picked 2009 as a starting period is
because it was six years versus six
years trying to get the Apples to Apples
as much as I understand that but I
understand your point certainly the
beginning of that started in a pretty
recessionary period yeah so that would
be helpful if we could have that
absolutely thank you
representative Shamrock
thank you madam chair I'm sorry I'm late
I hit PT this morning but appreciate it
thank you for taking my question uh
what about the
current Tech layoffs and the new
announcement this morning
at Yankee Candle of a 13 reduction in
its Workforce that is going to be uh
enforced soon
begin to see
in the next quarter a reduction of uh uh
bring forth enough revenue for for this
state
so so
I I'm willing to admit that I'm not an
economist by trade so so predicting what
might happen economically uh I will say
say that there's no question as we're
seeing the Federal Reserve uh go through
its current regime of of significant uh
interest rate rate hikes it obviously
doesn't help the economy uh on the other
hand inflation doesn't help the economy
either so you know you have to pick one
of the pick your poison there
I would say I would say that one of the
things that I've noted is that in New
Hampshire
and I think there's an interesting thing
to track
that even though our unemployment rate
is going up the number of employed
residents is also going up
uh
I will note that that based upon the
last uh the numbers that came out last
week a week ago to oh actually it was
Wednesday of last week because of the
holiday uh
noted that that we are still 6 000
people working fewer than we were in
pre-pandemic so six thousand fewer
people working
and our labor force is 10 000 people
fewer than it was prior to uh prior to
the coveted pandemic so
the big takeaway there is is that New
Hampshire employers are still hiring
they're still hiring uh and what's even
better is that more people are coming
back into the workforce
now that they're coming back into the
workforce in greater numbers and more
people are being employed obviously is
is something that we need to consider
but you talk to employers they think
that's a good thing not a bad thing
because they have more people applying
for those positions whereas it was a
pretty scarce and as someone who's who's
trying to do some hiring myself I will
say that I will say that it is for a
while it was pretty bleak out there and
and so the idea of more people
re-entering the workforce is a very
positive thing but to this to the extent
that that we may or may not have a
recession going forward
good news is is uh we haven't yet seen
that level of major layoffs here in New
Hampshire uh I guess that's speaks the
fact that we don't have any Tech Giants
working in our state I don't know if
that's a good or a bad thing as the
answers will vary uh but but we we've
had a pretty good run of it so far and
again
but you see the unemployment rate go up
it doesn't just necessarily mean things
are going bad if you see the
unemployment rate going up but the
number of employee people going down
that's obviously a sign of concern but
when the unemployment rate is going up
because more people are pulling being
pulled back into the workforce I think
that's actually a positive sign
for for New Hampshire for New Hampshire
not a lot of other states aren't seeing
that that same Dynamic where they're
seeing their employment rates go you
know the actual number of employed go
down thank you
thank you for your testimony thank you
we have seven more pink cards and 35
minutes so if I could ask the speakers
coming up to testify if you could leave
your remarks to about three minutes that
way we have a little bit of time for
questions representative Horgan could
um thank you very much for letting me
jump the queue so I'm representative
Timothy Horrigan from Stratford County
District 10 which is the town of Durham
my district keeps getting smaller every
10 years
um so I'm I'm opposed to this bill
because I don't think first of all I
don't think of any of the so-called
supply side effects that uh that are
that are being predicted
um predicted for this bill um I right
this doesn't necessarily mean a marriage
it was a long time ago but I actually
did study tax policy and economics with
the father supply side economics Arthur
B Laffer back when he's a young economic
professor at USC and he's University of
Southern California Navy is still around
and he would probably
if he was here he probably fell out a
pink card the other way saying he's in
favor of it but that's okay so the uh
we're talking
0.05 percent
um which is basically next to nothing so
this is not
um supply side effects kick in only when
you um
first of all only when you have a
significant change in the tax rate and
one that people are confident will be
around to make a difference and it also
only kicks in
um if you're incentivizing people to do
some businesses to do something
different than what they were doing
already so it's it's a tiny change you
could probably
lower the rate to zero Without Really
affecting the behavior of businesses at
all you wouldn't be doing anything
except uh reduce the amount of tax
revenue to the state
and um so I would uh I would just say
this uh bill is not it's not worth the
time it's not going to have any positive
it's not going to have any effect other
than simply merely reducing revenue and
also the incentives on the BET and you
know it's not a perfect tax and also
it's very very close to being an income
tax and the only thing that keeps you
from being broad-based is that it's only
applied to like certain types of
Enterprises not to every organization
economy but
um the
businesses are not businesses are not
going to reduce the amount of uh you
know the amount of whatever
the amount of work they do just because
uh just because of this tax even if we
lowered it from 0.55 to zero so 0.55 to
0.5 is just so minuscule it's not going
to make any difference at all so I would
just uh urge you to oppose the Bill
thank you
would you be open to questions I'm sure
yes I guess any questions
thank you so much for coming
okay we will uh next welcome up Mr Simon
thank you madam chair and members of the
House Ways and Means Committee my name
is Simon Thompson and I'm here on behalf
of the 1400 small businesses in New
Hampshire who are members of the
national Federation of Independent
businesses uh state director for nfib
Bruce Berkey submitted written testimony
I've passed that up this morning I'm not
going to read it I'm just going to touch
on a couple points
as we've heard House Bill 15 will reduce
the business Enterprise tax bet to the
rate of 0.5 of 1 percent
uh last year this legislator enacted the
final step in taking the business
profits tax down to the 7.5 percent but
unfortunately as we heard earlier the
BET did not make it cross the the finish
line and go to 0.5 but I do want to
remind members of this committee that
bet is a particular interest to the
small business community and our members
in New Hampshire because of its direct
impact on costs for a small business
a lot of new faces here on this
committee but some of the returning
members are aware the BET reduction was
first discussed during and by then
former Governor Hassan's Administration
seven years ago a series of four small
and prudent Cuts were enacted into law
the first two cuts were implemented but
the third and fourth were stalled due to
subsequent legislative action and of
course the pandemic
since the height of the pandemic the
third cut was enacted and now New
Hampshire's small businesses Community
is asking you to finally enact the final
cut so again on behalf of the 1400s
small business members in New Hampshire
I respectfully request that you consider
octopass on House Bill 15. thank you
very much
would you yield to questions thank you
anyone
representative
tell me first
on
their
how many of the do you know if on
how many of the 1400 small businesses in
New Hampshire which generally I think
you use a uh
a identifier of
the federal identifier which is under
500 employees so that's pretty much all
the businesses in New Hampshire on is
on is that true and do you know how many
of them pay BPT as well I do not know
how many of the 1400 members pay BPT
um I do know that most of our 1400
members are extremely small businesses
I'm talking two five maybe ten uh
employee companies so I do not know how
many pay both uh the BPT or bet all I do
know and we talked about this with with
our members
um last year uh similar to Mr Moore's
testimony you know we were kind of
hoping that if one was going to get
chopped off the block it was the BPT and
not the bet that's the one that impacts
our members
could I just do a quick follow-up quick
follow-up please thank you can you give
us a something that says how many
businesses are like under 25
and under
50 and above so you're kind of wanting a
little bit of a kind of a breakdown of
our membership in their sizes yes okay
thank you
representative Ulrich did you have a
question
yes thank you madam chair uh real
quickly uh you indicated that uh this
was an important tax for your members
um which represents the largest part of
the business community in the in the
state
um
because it had a direct impact upon
business costs that's a general phrase
could you give some specifics as to how
half a half of a half a percent
is going to affect the business I mean
the mom and pop store the Palmer's
Market or something like that is that
how does that affect that business and
to what degree yeah so I don't know if I
can answer to what degree as far as a
percentage or a dollar amount on on how
this will affect their bottom line but
the fact of the matter is despite prior
testimony
although very small reduction it is
still a reduction and when you have a
small business that is trying to just
keep the lights on keep maybe an extra
staff person on staff this little
reduction will be tremendously important
to them I do not have a specific dollar
amount that I can share with you
representative right now
we're very polite up here we defer to
um until until the until the end of the
um yeah so uh
perhaps you've noticed that the there's
a fiscal impact statement on this bill
um and the uh it's
it's uh phrased as the cumulative fiscal
impact of the proposed legislation
compared to current law
the uh the calculation that's here shows
that by the time this tax is fully in
place that's tax reduction is fully in
place the loss of Revenue
and again this is just a static analysis
would be about
28.3 million dollars
um
do you recognize that we will lose
revenue from uh tax cut Bill like this
even though it's a small rate there will
be a loss of Revenue overall and that
that will make it more difficult for the
state to provide services to your
membership well what I guess I would
answer that question is what I would
recognize is that over the last few
years as we've
progress with these tax cuts both BPT
and bet that that's not I mean the
revenue is increased and it's the
projections of the Ways and Means
Committee last year
um
we're good but we're we're we're far
outpacing them so
that would be the answer that question
um
do you uh phrase it the same way do you
recognize that in the last three years
there have been exceptional
circumstances including a huge amount of
federal funds flowing into the state
that have affected our uh revenues
significantly
I guess I would not recognize that
thank you
thank you for your testimony thank you
have a good day
okay well next I hope I get the
pronunciation right Catherine lauhead
from the tax Foundation thank you for
there we go thank you very much for the
chance to speak with you this morning my
name is Catherine lawhead I'm a senior
policy Analyst at the tax foundation and
if you're not familiar with the tax
Foundation we are a non-profit
non-partisan tax policy research
organization where based based in
Washington DC and we do not take a
position on any legislation but I wanted
to be here to share some informational
points with you today
as you know there are many things about
New Hampshire's tax code that make the
state especially attractive to
individual taxpayers most notably of
course is that New Hampshire and Alaska
are the only two states without a
broad-based individual income tax on
wage income and without a Statewide
retail sales tax and these factors are
really instrumental in New Hampshire
having the sixth best overall ranking on
the tax Foundation State business tax
climate index that's a report we've
published every year for the past 20
years that seeks to compare the
competitiveness of state's tax
structures
now tax policy is all about trade-offs
and because you have relatively low
taxes imposed directly on individuals
the result of that is that you end up
with pretty high taxes on businesses
including the business profits tax as
well as the business Enterprise tax
and when you look at the BPT
specifically alone by itself separate
from the BET and compare that rate to
the other states around the country New
Hampshire has the 16th highest corporate
income tax rate in the country
and um of course the BPT and the bet
both fall not just on C corporations but
on many other types of business entities
including small businesses LLC in many
different forms like LLCs Partnerships
proprietorships and others
now with that being said as the others
have mentioned both the BPT and the BET
have rightfully been prioritized for
reduction over the past few years so to
the extent that the state has the
ability to do so it would be wise to
continue working to reduce both of those
rates
and given New Hampshire's current budget
slur plus and history of strong Revenue
growth trimming the BET to 0.5 would
return extra tax revenue to taxpayers in
a manner that would make the state more
attractive to business investment and
long-term economic growth
in the fiscal note for House Bill 15 the
New Hampshire Department of Revenue
Administration estimates that the
reduction would reduce revenues by about
28.3 million dollars once the effects of
the reduction are fully felt and for the
sake of comparison New Hampshire brought
in about 2.2 billion dollars in tax
collections in FY 2022 so this tax cut
amounts to about 1.3 percent of actual
FY 2022 collections and this could
reasonably be expected to be paid for
out of the state's Revenue growth
without needing offsets
one thing I do want to note though is
that the BPT is the more economically
harmful of the two taxes so it is
something to take into consideration
when deciding how much to prioritize
reducing one versus the other the BPT is
a narrow-based high rate tax that
generates a relatively volatile source
of Revenue while the bet is a
comparatively broader based lower rate
tax that applies to more businesses but
it also generates a Stabler source of
Revenue and is less distortive in terms
of its effects on the on the economy and
on businesses economic decision making
so ultimately keeping both the BPT and
the BET rates on a downward Direction on
a downward trajectory will help generate
continued business investment and strong
economic growth here in New Hampshire
and I am happy to take any questions
representative ulery oh who's going
first representative Schamberg and then
thank you madam chair thank you
representative
thank you for taking my question the
question I have is do you have any uh
data to show the investment in long-term
growth statements that you make here
uh
from the past Cuts we've had
I don't have the specific numbers with
me at the time but looking at the GDP
trajectory we have seen a lot of growth
in New Hampshire as well as Revenue
growth I know in the past about decade
revenues have grown in nominal terms by
about 82 percent here and in real terms
I don't know the exact figure but the
state remains on a growth trajectory
despite all the cuts that have been made
over the past five or so years and so
that can be expected to continue
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question I've got uh two of
them here that you just said you seem to
be in your equating in your presentation
that a business uh Enterprise tax is
equivalent to an income tax can you just
flesh that out a little bit for the
committee let's explain how that works
sure of course you know it it's
comparable to an income tax but it is
more like an income based value-added
tax and so it is unique in the country
in being of this tax structure so it's
hard to compare it to really anything
else in the United States but because of
the way it is structured it ends up
being more like a universal consumption
tax which is a relatively less
economically distortive type of tax
compared to the BPT which is more like a
traditional corporate income tax that in
New Hampshire also applies to uh what
are traditionally passed through
businesses in other states
thank you um
I see other hands up let's go to them
first please representative fellows
thank you madam chair
um I'm new to the committee so I you
know some of these things are going
right over my head but your first bullet
here says that New Hampshire and Alaska
are are the only two states that don't
have an income tax or uh retail sales
tax
so I'm I know Alaska they have a lot of
oil money that they even give back to
their citizens so what in New Hampshire
where is the trade-off if we don't have
those where are we
you know shifting that cost to sure
absolutely and just to clarify there are
a number of other states that either
don't have an individual income tax or
that don't have a corporate income tax
but New Hampshire and Alaska are the
only two that don't have a wage income
tax or a retail sales tax on a Statewide
basis Alaska has local sales taxes but
because New Hampshire is pretty unique
in not having those two major taxes on
individuals you end up resulting in a
tax code that relies heavily on business
taxes and a number of smaller
taxes are generating more Revenue than
they might in other states that rely
more heavily on those major income and
I didn't hear you mention property taxes
that's an excellent point of course New
Hampshire does rely really heavily on
property taxes and as a source of
Revenue the real property tax is
considered one of the best Revenue
raisers there is I know it's not
politically popular because you know
people get the bill in the mail and they
pay it and it's often a large lump sum
but it relates closely the taxes that
are being paid on the property tax
relate really closely to the local
benefits received in a small state like
New Hampshire having a state property
tax levy makes some sense to it
generates a very stable source of
Revenue so it is one of the better taxes
while also avoiding some of the economic
other questions
yes it sounds like you agree with Mr
Thompson that there has been no effect
of the massive Federal stimuli that have
begun began in the Trump era and
continued in the Biden era
it's complicated is the short answer but
most of the revenue growth that has
occurred has been the result of
continued on Source Revenue growth in
States like New Hampshire where you know
businesses and individuals fared much
better throughout the pandemic than
anyone at first anticipated and so on
top of some of the federal stimulus
propping up people's incomes and
businesses incomes
that resulted in more Revenue but now
that we're out of the worst stages of
the pandemic we can expect continued
Revenue growth and you know to remain
back where we should be but even at a
thank you very much very much for your
testimony thank you
oh
one more question representative uh oars
thank you thank you madam chair thank
you for taking my question so you
mentioned New Hampshire you've mentioned
Alaska overall you're looking at I
believe all the states the entire in
Washington DC you're based there
are you finding that as these business
taxes go down Revenue overall goes up or
is what what are you seeing across the
country
that's a good question and the short
answer is that in general yes uh
business taxes are the most harmful in
terms of their impact on the economy and
so reductions in corporate income tax
rates have been shown to have one of the
biggest impacts in terms of helping
generate GDP growth in various States
there's a lot of academic literature out
there showing that corporate and then
individual income taxes have when those
rates are reduced States grow both in
terms of business investment and also in
terms of people wanting to live there
and being attracted to states where
their income isn't penalized in the same
way as it is elsewhere
thank you follow-up question please
follow up so just for clarification so
across the entire spectrum of the conus
we're seeing that as a business taxes go
down the health of the business so on
the revenues go up
is that correct that's correct
thank you very much of course thank you
again thank you
I would like to recognize David Trumbull
thank you for having me my name is David
Trumbull I'm from where New Hampshire
I'm a small business owner I stand
opposed to this bill for several reasons
first I believe it's fiscally
irresponsible the state has like Most
states around the country a surplus
right now that's a one-time Surplus
because of the massive trillions of
dollars that the federal government gave
to the states to help bail them out of
all the issues dealing with covid that
is around the country when that Surplus
ends we will not be able to fund the
programs that we need to run our state
adequately and by cutting this tax now
what you're basically saying to people
after that Surplus is gone too bad for
all those essential services that you
want the appropriate way to run a state
or any business is to have a steady
stream of Revenue coming in we should
not be cutting this tax at this time one
of the previous speakers said well we
can use the rainy day fund we all know
in New Hampshire that ready rainy day
fund never amounts too much and it's
very small we said we can all
alternative Revenue Services sources New
Hampshire does not pass any of these
major alternative Revenue sources so
there's really no other way to do it
this policy exists we should maintain
this tax in place second is we need
Public Services individuals and
businesses count on our towns our
municipalities our cities in the state
to provide essential Services whether
it's substance abuse or Roads
Maintenance or helping our seniors our
nursing homes all of these are essential
services without them our businesses
cannot Thrive if you cut off at the
knees our municipalities and our towns
from providing these Services you will
be doing significant damage to the
business Community as well as to the
individuals in this state an earlier
speaker talked about promises being made
we have to live up to them we had a
promise about this tax made so many
years ago we made promises decades ago
that we have not lived up to in this
state we closed the state hospital and
promised to set up a functioning
Community Mental Health Services around
the state and we never fully funded it
we have all these lawsuits going back to
Claremont that said we will deal with
the poor town a poor property Town
versus Rich property Town dilemma and
we've never dealt with that either we
have decades-old promises that we have
not met in this state and the only way
to do that is of adequate funding
cutting funding now will mean that we're
saying to those old promises well we're
never going to deal with you the last
question is what's the how that's the
best way to build your economy some
people say trickle down some people say
build up I would say the best way to
build a strong economy is from the
ground up we need strong schools in this
state the property poor towns cannot
adequately fund their their schools they
are spending around fifteen or sixteen
thousand dollars per pupil the property
Rich towns are spending almost 30 000
per pupil what does that mean that means
that either you fix the roof or you have
programs for the gifted children you
have special ed and you have other
programs in your schools the property
poor towns can't do it all you look at
those schools look at the proficiency
results at the Department of Education
websites and compare a property rich
town with a property poor town right
next to each other and you'll see a
massive difference the property poor
towns have so many children who are at
level one the property Rich towns have
so many children at level four it's
there the money makes a difference and
this leads to a generational issue where
many people in these property poor towns
they don't go to college their children
don't go to college because they weren't
brought up in a family that says you're
going to go to college if you went to
college your children are more likely to
go there when you do your income goes up
when your income goes up your ability to
pay taxes goes up if you want to build a
stable long-term Revenue source for New
Hampshire fund your schools if you cut
this tax you won't be able to adequately
fund your schools so I would urge you to
please do not pass these tax reductions
thank you
thank you for your testimony would you
be open to questions of course
representative plett
I had trouble following the link between
this business Enterprise taxes being
discussed and uh school funding I
thought that came from swept so
enlighten me
okay the relationship is this you can
say that's a separate piece of the pie
it has nothing to do with it but when
you sit down to look at how the state
budget all gets put together you have a
giant pie and so if the total revenue is
reduced the size of the pie is reduced
so then when you go over to look at
property tax rather school funding
you're going to say okay we have less
money available the size of the pie is
smaller if you have a bigger amount of
funding then you don't have so many
competing concerns it's you can't really
uh actually say that they're completely
separate because it's one giant state
budget
representative Schamberg
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question may I inquire what
type of small business uh you're in I'm
welcome
thank you so much for your testimony
you're welcome oh
see some more hands representative orrs
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question so
rep schemberger took away my first uh
question so you're a farmer uh I I do
agree with your position on the rich
towns to poor towns thank you very much
uh but as was asked
don't know how that plays in with this
uh are you an economist no sir okay so
what is your
basis for your opinions I mean where did
you get your how did you form your
opinions based on what well I am a
farmer I'm also a lawyer trained in New
Hampshire I practice law and I've been a
college debate coach for 44 years so
every year we debate these issues the
issues that you're debating we debate
them all so I've been studying this from
an academic perspective for a long time
I pay my taxes I run a business I have
employees so I just bringing my life
experience to testify here okay so
you're in a tournament excuse me is
there a follow-up yes let's let me
remind the members uh that we are not
here to question the uh testifiers we're
here to ask clarifying questions to
understand their testimony so just be
aware of that thank you thank you madam
chair
I think I'll stop there then thank you
very much thank you so much
thank you you're welcome thank you very
much
okay we'll recognize Dennis Hall from
thank you
good morning to all of you and thank you
for the opportunity to testify here
today my name is Dennis Hall I am state
affairs coordinator at Americans for tax
reform we are an organization non-profit
based out of DC and I'm here on behalf
of Grover norquist and my organization
to urge you guys to support HP 15 and
this critical tax relief for small
businesses and companies throughout New
Hampshire
so in my short time
in the world of policy I've realized
that the rhetoric surrounding corporate
income taxes has largely obscures the
nature and the impact of these taxes a
lot of people think it's some pie in the
sky abstract entity that pays these
taxes but in reality it's paid by you
and me when we go to the store and pay
higher prices it's paid by employees of
these companies who often do not have as
high of a wage as they would otherwise
when the federal government takes 21 of
all corporate income entrepreneurs
suffer from a lack of opportunity to
invest greater funds in their productive
capacities
and grow their business and investments
in the state and I think this is
particularly relevant for small
businesses who tend to suffer from a
smaller profit margins a lack of
extensive infrastructure and a harder
time finding employees particularly in a
labor shortage when they're up against
large companies with significantly more
funding and ability to take on debt
reducing the business Enterprise tax
rate gives a real opportunity to
thousands of small businesses to compete
for Quality Labor offer higher wages to
their employees and expand investment in
their productive capabilities across the
state of New Hampshire and I won't deny
that point zero five percent is a
relatively small number but we have to
remember that just six short years ago
the rate was 0.75 percent which means we
have given small businesses an effective
tax cut of more than 25 percent in just
six years and this is another
opportunity
to invest in our small businesses across
the state and offer the opportunity for
more small businesses and entrepreneurs
to move here and raise their families
and live and work here it is these small
steady and consistent reforms that add
up and make New Hampshire the most
competitive economy in the Northeast and
prove to Americans across the country
that this is the place to work to live
and to start and succeed as an
entrepreneur so I commend you for the
progress that has already been made and
I hope you will consider embracing this
new opportunity to offer even greater
relief to current and potential
residents and businesses in New
Hampshire thank you for your time
would you be open to questions I
wouldn't thank you uh representative all
me
thank you madam chair
do do you
what do you think the state of New
Hampshire should be depending on for the
essential services that the businesses
need and that they are not getting
enough of even now
the local property tax only
I do agree with much of what Miss Lau
had said about um sort of having a
broad-based tax system I would prefer
um not necessarily a higher sales tax
rate but sales and property taxes are
generally a better way to go and these
are the policies that we would support
over something like an income tax or
even a corporate income tax particularly
for small businesses and with the
business Enterprise tax if you lower
this rate you're giving small businesses
the opportunity to succeed and gain
enough income to the point where they do
reach the level where they're subject to
the business profits tax and at that
point they're paying more than seven
percent and that's significantly more
revenue for the State of New Hampshire
so if you offer these small businesses
the opportunity to become medium or
large size businesses the revenue would
increase in that sense
um but I would I would always support a
sales sales or property tax over
something like an income tax or a
corporate income tax because these costs
are indeed paid by real people and tend
to impacts the economy in ways that are
any more questions
um
no
if you could both uh introduce
yourselves that'd be great good morning
my name is Kean Ming Wong I'm a tax
policy councilor at the Department of
Revenue
good morning my name is Lauren
O'Sullivan I am the senior Financial
the department does not have a position
on this bill we prepared a fiscal note
on this on this bill and we're here to
answer any questions on it
um I've passed around our physical no
quick guide describing how we come to
oh great representative Olney
thank you I've been waiting to ask you
about this on their
we don't know but you may know how many
of the businesses that pay business
Enterprise tax are also paying business
profits tax
on and my question is did You account
for the people that were paying would
have been were paying business
Enterprise tax at 5.5 going down to
0.055 to 0.05 and then having to pay the
business profits tax on that 0.005
on did you account for what we gain from
relative to the ones that pay less
right no our calculations did not
account for for that move of the um of
from BET to BBT our calculations
essentially took all the uh the data
from the the bad payers and the revenue
that we received from from bet this is
from the fiscal year
um 20 basically 22 and from there we did
Static analysis
um projecting that uh the revenue impact
going forward using the tax rate changes
from there
um and
and that that's the results uh on that
so the the fiscal impact showing in that
table before fiscal year 24 25 and 26
with the final cumulative fiscal impact
of 28 million
um we did not account for uh any
movements with with the BPT
just follow up follow up on is it
possible to do that
foreign
we can look into it to see if we can to
do that calculation yeah thank you
representative Platt
yes the numbers on the table uh on the
bill they are a static analysis that is
correct
we'll be hearing a lot more from the dra
coming up so just keep that in mind
uh the fiscal impact that you've given
us appropriately is is addressed to this
specific uh rate cut in this bill can
you provide us
um
you've done it in pieces in the past but
with the entirety of the loss of Revenue
that has come with the movement from the
tax as it was
whatever it was five years ago
that that rate to the present
you see what I'm asking
yes yep we'll work on that but I do want
to mention that our calculations here
um
so we use the the fiscal year 22 cache
basis and then um we did account for the
the six percent uh bet and then the
point six percent to the point five five
percent bet uh rate reduction I'm
assuming that's not what you're
referring to representative
I didn't quite you what was your
starting point there uh
so a starting point for fiscal year 22
Cash basis no I want to go back further
to the start of the rate decline okay
any other questions on this
thank you for being here to answer oh we
have one over here yes representative
spilsbury thank you madam chairman I
just want to clarify that I understand
the comments in the fiscal note
regarding the effect on the education
trust fund
am I correct in understanding that
statute guarantees a half a percent
to the education trust fund
and therefore that the cut from 0.55 to
0.5
would come entirely out of the general
fund and have no impact on the education
the way it's it's being calculated right
now the uh with point five five percent
there is a percentage of the BET Revenue
that goes to the general fund and then
uh to the education trust fund as well
with a reduction of the 0.552. uh 0.05
uh 0.55 to 0.5 percent
at point five percent the way the
statute is written the entire bet
Revenue
collected would go to the education
trust fund with nothing going to the
general fund
so if if I understand you the Practical
effect is to confirm what I just
presumed
I think it's slightly different than
than um than what you've mentioned but
um the way that I've discussed that I
mentioned just now is the way the
statute calculates uh that directs the
calculation of the the funds going into
which uh they're Revenue going into
which for either the general fund or the
education trust fund
this is something we can clarify over
coming weeks absolutely yes thank you so
much
okay anymore I think we're all up one
more representative fellows this is just
one tiny question
um a previous speaker said at one time
the um the rate was
0.75 so can you tell do you know
anything about the history of
where the what the rights have been I
don't even know how long the program's
been in place yes um so the the history
of the tax rates are on our website and
uh so back in the rates that I have
right now uh the historical race right
now is I had the earliest is 0.75
percent
and this was for taxable years ending
before December 31 2016. and it's been
going down steadily um
through legislative process through
right now is 0.55 for uh tax peers
okay thank you very much
okay seeing no other people here to
testify we will close the public hearing
foreign
we will now open up the public hearing
on House Bill 133 relative to repealing
the communications Services tax
and for the record I pay that tax but
will participate
foreign
there are several of us in this
committee who are co-sponsors of this
bill I just remembered and so that means
if you're going to testify you cannot
also be questioning the presenters so
welcome to reason means I recognize
representative Jason Osborne
Prime sponsor
thank you madam chair Jason Osborne
Rockingham uh two the towns of Auburn
Candia and Deerfield uh I am double
booked this morning so I'll get out of
your hair very quickly and if my
reputation precedes me uh you know I I
do like to be brief and I I do like
myself some tax cuts
so uh just real quickly um I'm not going
to tell you anything you don't already
know I'm sure about this uh particular
tax I know you've been working on it for
the last couple years uh as well just
real quickly the reason I brought it to
you uh this morning
it's a it's a relatively uh small tax
only about 30 million dollars in change
uh per year and I would like to just uh
suggest that
um
you know uh fully repealing a tax is uh
sometimes better than just uh reducing
tax and leaving it on the books there
are some fixed costs associated with
collecting attacks that uh that are the
same no matter you know what what the
what the tax rate is
um so
getting rid of that can be a good thing
I think we can all agree to that what we
might not agree on uh is that uh you
know getting rid of attacks entirely
makes it much harder to bring back in
the future as opposed to increasing an
existing tax and so uh I think we can
agree on that point but maybe what we
don't agree on is whether that's a good
thing or a bad thing right I I would
suggest that uh that raising taxes is is
not good and therefore repealing one
entirely is is a benefit I would suggest
though that uh that of the tax uh cut or
repeal bills that you have to work on
this year this one is probably low
priority
the only reason I suggested it was just
because of the the relatively low dollar
amount I would hope that you would
strongly consider instead tackling
further the interest in dividends tax
which we already have set on the path to
being repealed in the future that being
I think the the probably the worst of
all possible taxes and that is a
disincentive on on savings which is the
very lifeblood of our human evolution I
mean without saving and deferring
consumption we would all you know still
be living in the woods eating twigs and
Chipmunks or whatever people in the
woods do I'm not in survival class
that's my kids so
um I I quite enjoy my uh my restaurants
um so uh that's all I have to say and
I'll uh be out of your hair if I may
would you understand questions I I would
if you really need to but uh like I said
I probably can't help you you guys are
the experts here so
representative Almy has a question it'll
be brief okay yes thank you uh this is
the same one I asked someone last time
uh how uh how do you think that we
should be funding the government
services in New Hampshire
well I think we have a a large number of
taxes on the on the books that we use to
fund the services in the state of New
Hampshire and all I might suggest is
that uh I
thank you so much for your testimony
okay next we'll now recognize Dennis
you guys
um again I'm Dennis Hall with Americans
for tax reform
um I will start with an anecdote
I was formally paying almost a hundred
dollars a month for cell phone service
when I turned 18. I was totally on my
own no support from my parents so I got
a bunch of my friends together
to create a family plan
um for cell phone service so I have
eight people on our plan we spend like
300 something dollars a month but it
gives me an opportunity to see what the
actual tax burden is when it comes to
having multiple people on a line and we
spend almost fifty dollars a month on
taxes and a large part of this I was
thinking about this issue before I even
saw this bill in New Hampshire and a
large part of this is the fact that the
federal government has a 12.24 percent
rate on all Wireless Services it's
essentially a sales tax on top of an
additional sales tax that's charged on
these services and some states have
rates that top 20 percent we're talking
sales tax rates for for wireless service
that is almost 35 percent in some states
and New Hampshire has a relatively low
rate here but this is an opportunity for
New Hampshire to become what I believe
is the first state to get rid of this
tax entirely and also take another step
towards making New Hampshire a true no
sales tax state it's a sort of a lot
like the interest in dividends tax is
the the one thing holding New Hampshire
back from from being a true no income
tax state the wireless tax is definitely
a type of sales tax and it's sort of a
workaround in the absence of an actual
state tax that most people don't
recognize until they're forced to really
confront it for themselves and a lot of
these costs are also embedded into the
wireless service so I believe that this
would be it doesn't make New Hampshire
sort of a model for other states
particularly a lot of Republican states
even Nebraska has a rate of 19.49
percent combined state and local for
their Wireless taxes and if we did this
here in New Hampshire I believe quite a
few other
um
reform-minded States would follow suit
and New Hampshire would get the credit
for being the first to take this action
so I don't have much else to say but I
think that this is a meaningful reform
that really wouldn't have that large of
an impact on state revenue and would
also simplify the tax code and make New
Hampshire a true no sales tax state so
that's all I have thank you and for the
members uh knowledge our rate right now
for the communication Services tax is
seven percent so you know a
representative Albany has a question
would you be open to questions
absolutely thank you representative
thank you uh in the last hearing you
said that preferably we should be using
sales and property taxes so why should
we go after a sales tax now I do think
with a couple hundred million of dollars
in the bank
um reducing reducing spending overall
and using these surplus funds on uh
relief for ordinary people in New
Hampshire to make the economy and the
state overall more competitive is really
a striking contrast to States like
California to name one extreme example
which used more than 100 billion dollars
worth of Surplus on new programs that
they knew that they couldn't fund and
they're already facing a shortfall for
this year the fact that New Hampshire
does not have a sales tax is admirable
there are other sources of government
revenue that have given the state a
booming and booming economy and a pretty
massive Surplus until the state does run
into problems with the way the tax is
structured eliminating taxes wherever we
can or at least lowering the rates is
preferable to using this money on
whatever new programs could be thought
of or invented other states have proven
that there is no end or limit to the
amount of things the government can and
will spend money on depending on which
special interest groups have the most
power
um
and I think this is a very small impact
and isn't necessarily a sales tax but it
is a workaround that would be better to
thank you very much
okay we will now recognize Catherine
Longhead again from tax Foundation thank
you
Madam chair and members of the committee
thank you again for the chance to
testify again my name is Catherine
lawhead with the tax foundation and we
do not take a position on legislation
but it's good to share some information
with you about the communication
Services tax
as you know houseboat 133 would repeal
the attacks effective July 1st 2023
now currently New Hampshire levisa
communication Services taxed at a rate
of seven percent in addition to a
separate 9-1-1 tax of 75 cents per
transaction so this yields a combined
state tax of approximately 9.1 percent
on the non-data portion of a New
Hampshire resident's cell phone bill
this is actually well below the national
average so this isn't necessarily A
competitiveness issue for New Hampshire
but because there's actually little
economic justification for wireless
Services taxes to begin with reducing or
even eliminating this tax could be worth
considering
while the federal government and all 50
states do Levy some form of Wireless
Services tax this is not necessarily
something that makes a whole lot of
sense because ideally when States Levy
excise taxes on specific goods or
services or activities those taxes
should either function as a type of user
fee or they should seek to recoup the
negative externalities associated with
that activity or try to pay for programs
that help address the cost to society
created by that activity
as an example gas taxes and Highway
tolls are like user fees in that
generally speaking the people who are
paying the most in those taxes are the
ones who are contributing most to the
wear and tear on the roads and can most
benefit from funding for Road upkeep
meanwhile excise taxes on things like
alcohol should ideally only generate
Revenue to be used to mitigate the
negative externalities associated with
alcohol use disorder or with drunk
driving and things like that
now a lot of States go above this and
try to Target these taxes
and raise taxes on these activities to
just raise General Revenue for the state
and this is sort of what is occurring
here with the wireless Services tax
because when it's added onto your cell
phone bill oftentimes you know you have
a number of line items on your bill and
you don't know exactly what they're
going toward you just pay what you're
being asked to pay and you know might be
annoyed but not think much of it besides
that wireless taxes however are unlike
both gas taxes or alcohol taxes and that
they are mostly just a revenue generator
for the general fund they're not a type
of user fee and they aren't trying to
recoup some sort of negative externality
because I think we can all agree that in
general cell phone use is
um creating a net benefit for society
and that there's not really a negative
externality that we should be trying to
mitigate here
so again in Most states Wireless taxes
are generally just another source of
Revenue even to the extent that the 911
Tax that's separate from the
communication Services tax but to the
extent that that tax is being used to
pay for 9-1-1 Services there's a little
economic justification for imposing that
on the cell phone bill
uh because how much a consumer pays for
their cell phone service has no relation
to how much they are likely to rely on
9-1-1 or 988 Services
um now 98 911 and 988 services are broad
services that are available to the
public broadly so they should be
considered General publicly provided
Goods that are funded through the
general fund through broad-based taxes
I will also add to this that wireless
Services taxes are regressive in that as
a percentage of income the taxes impose
higher tax burdens on lower income
taxpayers than on higher income
taxpayers
so policy makers should ideally avoid
increasing the communication Services
tax to excessively high levels I would
steer clear of what other states have
done in imposing rates as high or even
higher than 20 percent especially
because these taxes do not meaningfully
internalize any kind of external harm
and with that I'm happy to answer any
questions
representative roachford
thank you madam chair
um in regards to the wireless services
are regressive uh and negatively impact
lower income taxpayers so understanding
this tax and how it's assessed and onto
what services it says do are when you go
to Walmart and you buy these single-use
phones the TracFones or whatever do do
are those taxed as well
I do believe the tax applies to all
two-way communication services so my
understanding is that yes it would apply
to that as well
okay we now have the folks from the uh
dra who are here to answer any questions
thank you Keen Wong and Lauren
good morning Representatives my name is
Kim Ming Wong from the Department of
Revenue Administration
my name is Lauren O'Sullivan also from
the Department of Revenue Administration
I've just passed around a fiscal no
quick guide in regards to the fiscal
note that we prepared for the uh for
this bill
and uh we'll
the department does not have a position
on this bill and we're here to answer
any questions
okay hopefully you have seen this quick
representation has a question
thank you madam chair
um do we know how what the amount of out
of that 30 million is the um 911
portion
this does not include the 9-1-1 that's
separate
representative fellows
thank you madam chair
um I I don't understand why that why
it's going down why the revenue is going
down I mean it seems to me you know data
services cell phones that there's even
just more and more of them why is it the
rate going down
yes we did uh notice that the uh the
rate uh the revenue from the revenue
from CSD has gone down and um and
we do see that it is likely because of
the way the uh Communication service
providers are building their customers
these uh
the way that they're bifurcating the the
charges as opposed to data versus voice
data is something that's not subject to
communication Services tax whereas The
Voice portion of the bill will be
subject to the CST and uh when in this
when the service providers say um that
okay
based on however their method of billing
or they're providing the service to say
okay
a majority of our service is more for
data than as a smaller portion of the
bill is then relative to the voice piece
and therefore subject to cscop over
follow up
um so you know if maybe if there's an
example
um I'm thinking one of the things that
that happened during covet is people
started using Zoom you know and that
they're communicating they're
communicating verbally is that is that
but if they're doing it on their
computer they're not not getting taxed
for that because it goes over the
Internet or so two-way all two-way
Communications will be subject to the
CST so including providers like Zoom so
any kind of two-way communication from
Zoom
um with a video or through the telephone
maybe we could ask someone from the
communications providers to help us with
that to help us understand that okay
yes representative Ames
just just pursuing this question
um is there a standard that uh that
could help both the providers and The
Regulators
sort between that which is subject to
this text and that which is not I mean
they they're separating out
a piece the uh the provider that
provides us with the service on our cell
phones is separating out a piece of that
that is I guess data you call it
something like that and the and the
voice and um
um and their their tendency in recent
years has been to push more of that into
the data the non-taxable piece as far as
this tax is concerned
um and uh uh what limits are there
to that what is what is the standard
that applies to being in this cubby hole
I would say that um that currently is a
function of our audit process I do know
that um
we we do have CST audits our audit
department at the dra do perform CST
Audits and as part of that function we
do review
um as to um
what exactly would be the uh the the
two-way Communication Service piece
um and then everything else will then
fall back to the statute will be just uh
follow what's presents required by the
statute in terms of what is a two-way
communication and what is uh providing
follow up on the last two
my interpretation of this is that the
the VoIP the voiceover Internet Protocol
people were not being charged this tax
could we get information on the revenue
from
people like zoom and other VoIP
providers to see if they are paying this
tax
so you wish to see the um the CSD
revenue from these uh VoIP providers yes
because I too if if indeed they are
subject to this tax I guess I'm curious
why the revenue isn't going up
especially given how much we use those
Services since the pandemic um I'm not
sure we're able to disclose that that
sort of information are specific to any
provider because can you provide it as a
lump as all VoIP people we'll have to
depend on the amount of VoIP providers
if the
if in the market and within the CST
Market
um in New Hampshire if the number of
providers is is a very small amount
um it will be uh you will not be able to
disclose uh specific information
in regards to that so but we will look
into that and see if we can provide that
again this I'm new to Ways and Means so
this might be a question I should know
the answer to but
um
I'm also wondering
how we tax if the service is delivered
in New Hampshire right if I'm consuming
Zoom here in New Hampshire and they
don't necessarily have headquarters here
maybe the taxes are different because of
that as well so I guess I'm just curious
if we're capturing or if we're trying to
capture a tax on that
so the CST tax is a tax that would be
paid by the consumer and collected by
the provider
so if I'm not mistaken the uh the
location of the provider would not
determine whether the
service is subject to cstni so it's the
consumer so I should be able to look at
my own
Zoom Bill and see this tax listed on
them I believe it's
based on the mailing address of the end
user so for example I have someone from
New York on my family plan and they're
subject to the New Hampshire tax is not
the New York State and New York City
taxes
thank you very much
representative Army
thank you um
representative uh rajford
was speaking earlier about the track
phones the people who are on track
phones and the people who are on real
landlines is versus mine which is run by
Comcast cable uh
are still I believe paying the full
seven percent of the cost
of the real of the real price of the
product whereas the people on
cable
and the people who are on I don't know
how they would
uh anyway on the people who are on cable
and other forms of uh VoIP or whatever
on would be paying whatever the company
manages to convince you is the cost of
Just The Voice
and my phone bills have gone down quite
a lot in terms of calls because on they
convinced you or you hadn't done audits
of them of that on the costs per call is
a lot less than what it used to be
so which may be true I'm not sure
um but my zoom Bill consists of I'm
foolishly perhaps because I'm not using
it paying 150 a year for a license
I don't think anybody gets
a zoom bill
who isn't paying for a license is there
a question the question is does that
um I do know that the customers for
track for those uh prepaid
um
calling services they do they do uh also
subject to the CST And in regards to
um the the cable providers and um how
they are allocating the costs to the the
uh The Voice phone services that they
provide versus all the other services
um I I'm not aware of of that the trend
that's happening right now with those
with those cable companies
representative Doucette
thank you madam chair thanks for taking
my question I'm curious as to the
history of the CST tax how long ago was
implemented
that information is in the annual report
okay
um we don't have that information right
I think we'll find it in the tech in the
on dra historical records but it it goes
back to a time when we got rid of a
whole bunch of troublesome little taxes
and this is one of the ones they put in
instead follow-up so it looks like we
have some follow-up questions for you on
this so anything you find out could you
please email all the committee members
and it sounds like maybe I'll reach out
to some of the service providers and see
if they can shed any light or their
thoughts on this but there's not a lot
of these service providers so that's why
they may not be able to give too much
detail because then you might be able to
figure out who those are I understand
that but maybe they can at least explain
their thoughts on Zoom versus VoIP and
all this other stuff yes representative
ulrey
yeah Madam chair I believe the concept
of a tax on Communications goes back to
the Spanish-American War when only the
rich had telephones
is there a question there though
oh that was to me okay
I will not answer that question
yes representative you said just uh
thank you madam chair and thank you for
the follow-up the the point I wanted to
get to was the his his history in this I
know for one and others have brought up
my cell phone bill for instance as
opposed to a landline bill was
substantially higher back a few years
ago so my
guess is the tax in Revenue was
substantially higher so I'd like to see
what those rates were maybe back eight
years ago and where we are now okay and
we're talking about uh 30 30.9 million
and and what the revenue was at its at
its peak and where we are right now in
representative fellows I I don't know if
this would be helpful or not but this is
not a question but like I brought in my
tax bill I'm in my my phone bill which
is a lamp real landline so if other
people could
bring in their bills and maybe we could
get some better idea of like who's
getting taxed and how much
represent Ames
just I happen to have my computer open I
think I was doing the right kind of
thing with it I wasn't doodling
um
this tax was first enacted in 1990 this
is the dra annual report that's a
blurbed there that lays it all out at
5.5 percent that's where it started and
then uh there was a surtax that was put
on it in 2001 that added 2.5 so that
brings it up to seven percent which is
where we are now
and then uh there was this question of
two-way communication Services which way
back then wasn't a question you know you
just had your telephones but uh the
complications that we're talking about
are more recent and I don't know whether
there's
any added language that helps us figure
out get the question I asked how do you
differentiate between what's taxable and
what's not so I look forward to getting
thank you very much for your testimony
we will see you back
after lunch thank you okay seeing no
other pink hearts
we will close the public hearing on
we are now in lunch break until one
o'clock so that worked out well so enjoy
your lunch and we'll see you back here
foreign
we will now open the public hearing on
House Bill 192 and recognize
representative almi
thank you madam chair
um oh and I should I just for the record
I do pay this tax as well and so do I
okay I put that disclaimer at the end of
this
um
the
the first sentence at this point was on
is changed by what the governor said
this morning which is oh I'm feeling
much better about our our revenues at
this point and I think that we can
probably cut some taxes he wants tax
credits as well I haven't seen a tax
credit yet but that's what he wants
um
but it is still true that we need to be
very careful with our budgeting this
year
we are just exiting from under the
largest bucket of stimulus money ever to
be dropped on our state and National
economies
and we don't know how well our
businesses and residents Will Survive
Beyond it
we have major unmet needs to maintain
our economy lack of housing for all
levels of workers High property taxes
affecting most workers
child and elder care costs
workers access to Medical Care addiction
and mental health treatment public
transit and Road and Bridge maintenance
and a bunch of other things
and on top of that on New Hampshire's
voluntary social service agencies do a
lot of the government's work that is
done in other states by the government
for the Working Poor and disadvantaged
and when there is less state revenue
their reimbursements have been left in
the past several times in my time here
at pre-inflation rates for years and
paid late or never
in order to balance a budget
and we lost in Lebanon the only
um
home for unwed soon-to-be mothers that
took them through the coming mothers and
getting stable and sent them out into
the community and took their children
and as for child care and such and made
them productive citizens and that was
because they dared to sue the state
because they had been paid never for six
months
for the reimbursements they were
supposed to get
there were five other agencies around
the state that the same thing happened
to I don't know if they all died
New Hampshire requires more investment
not less
but since 2016 the solution has been to
cut state level taxes and make it
impossible to invest to grow and thrive
every year the business LED Council on
state taxations has calculated the tax
and fee burden to each State's
businesses each year they have reported
that in New Hampshire the corporate
income tax which they equate with both
BPT and bet
represents less than two-thirds what the
average business pays in property taxes
we are our businesses our normal our
average businesses are paying more in
property taxes than they are in uh
profit taxes
and that
um obviously differs if you've got a
small office handling a huge amount of
transactions
than if you've got a Walmart but
um we have been cutting State business
taxes not the property taxes the efforts
at reducing the property tax have been
one time and are usually biased towards
helping the wealthiest communities not
where most businesses are located
we have a very old requirement in our
laws that municipalities are the place
of Last Resort for the Indigent and have
to help them
every time the state faces a deficit the
governor of the time starts to cut
school or Municipal Aid or programs that
the municipalities cannot afford to lose
such as support to the homeless and to
the hungry
even without a recession in 2023 to 4
revenues are likely to decline somewhat
this year from the peak created by the
federal stimulus and to drop sharply in
2024. the business taxes including the
IND tax are the key part of this problem
there are three-sevenths of all General
and education trust revenue and that is
after years of cuts
and they are the most volatile
they made up 61 percent of our Surplus
in the first six months of this fiscal
year
our interest in dividends tax seems that
revenues seem to be dropping
we won't really know until April May
and the BET has been flirting with
coming in below the plan that this
committee estimated in early 2021 when
the clouds of recession seemed near
the stock market has been declining as
the federal stimulus Pat packages end
and the war on Ukraine continues and
most economists expect a recession
though some of them are peddling back to
a softer session or a slow session or
some such word
um those do hit
the smallest businesses worst the slow
recessions
on
why
are these dropping we cut bptbt rates
multiple times starting in 16. in 19 and
21 we made structural changes to the BPT
market-based sourcing single sales
factor and credit carry forward
depletion these were all made
um
well I'll go into that in a minute and
and the interest in dividends rate
changes
will cost us at least 100 million
relative to the 2019 Baseline starting
in 2024 and working their way up under
current law or happening immediately
next year
on
I'd like to say the market-based
sourcing was something that seems to be
working out
on it changed the basis of what is taxed
in intangibles in on
in New Hampshire
and
it's going and we seem to be able to
find as many places that on outside the
state that weren't paying for them as we
were losing
to other states because they were being
sold to Massachusetts and further south
on the single sales factor is another
and extremely difficult thing to measure
we're just going to have to wait until
2024 and 2025 to see what happened to us
but it is based on the idea that the
BPT is only
only taxes sales inside the state
on if we a lot of our business of our
manufacturing businesses they produce
widgets and fancy machines and all sorts
of stuff on using a little bit of
imports from outside the state that they
buy inside the state
but they then send them back out of the
state
across the country and across the world
and those we will not be able to tax
from the outside there are things that
that businesses outside are going to be
selling us
that we can tax
but we are an old we're one of the
oldest states in the country we don't
consume as much as other people
and our businesses are not based on
bringing a lot of value in to add a
so
it looks quite
possible that we could end up with a
very unpleasant surprise in 24.
or 25 I'm not sure how long it takes for
this to activate
um
but it is based it is it started this
and the dra has been trying to find the
businesses that are outside the state
that we'll be selling in
so
um
the committee last term and the term
before fought bitterly and bipartisanly
against single sales Factor
we were trying to keep it from occurring
until we've had enough years of multi
market-based sourcing that we can get
some kind of idea of what this is going
to do to us
but both the governor and the Senate
wanted to do it and we couldn't get a
budget without it in 2019.
so
um then the last one is credit carry
forward depletion
that was a bug of air of Representative
Majors which the rest of us I think came
to appreciate a lot more as it grew it's
up above 300 million dollars sitting in
the treasury which it we owe to the
companies that did not uh
remove their overpayments from
the treasury
so for whatever reason and we had a
number of thoughts about it on they were
leaving it there
we have the possibility that in a bad
recession
companies could come to the treasury and
say I want my piece of that 300 million
back
and so we finally last term put into the
budget bipartisanly uh a very carefully
calculated reduction in that over a
period of years in which the real damage
or benefit comes in
the fifth and sixth year I think giving
enough time for the finance committee to
panic and say you're taking away too
much money we can't do this any longer
so
um the federal stimulus has hidden these
effects of of the structural changes and
the rate changes first the Trump era tax
cuts and job acts jobs act resulted in
large profits
for the largest copper corporations as
they took back the tax cuts that had
been repealed
by that bill on we paid we they then had
to pay us on taxes business taxes
business profits taxes that is on the
extra profits that they'd gotten from
the federal government
uh
then came the Trump error cares act and
then a sequence of Biden narrow stimulus
bills to reinvest in America as we
survived the pandemic
they caused inflation but they kept
households and businesses alive and
paying taxes and
paying taxes to us as well
now as the stimulus bills narrow to a
few areas of focus and District of
Columbia won't be coming to rescue us is
not the time to be cutting the state's
revenues when we have no idea what
stability is going to look like
HB 192 revives the IND tax at its
long-standing rate of five percent but
updates the exemptions which have been
frozen in place since 1977.
there are a lot of people paying them
who are lower middle income some even
low income that
um
that really shouldn't be paying them
anymore
and
and a lot of people who have been filing
return which comes out as zero which is
why we already did this kind of of
increase in the floor for the BET and
the BPT to get rid of all these filers
who had zero
zero payments to make
my estimate is that removing these
people would cost us about 5 million a
year it's based on the dra's inverted
triangles but tries to account for the
joint filers and multiple Exempted
filers by a total guesstimate on my part
I'd hope the dra would have slightly
better methodology for this than I
probably not yet but maybe if we asked
them to try
but but my bill leaves about 95 percent
of the tax available to a straight
treasury that may be severely tried in
fiscal year 24 and Beyond if we do not
stop cutting our investments in our
current and Future workforces
and
disclosure I pay this tax please don't
would you entertain questions
very thorough wonderful oh
um
if you can can you um
relate the history of the int text when
was it roughly when was it started five
point when was its rate set at the right
before this recent decline uh set on
that kind of thing so we can have a
perspective on this tax I believe it's
one of our longest standings yes
Statewide taxes it is I think it is the
longest side the property tax was the
longest
and the property tax was originally
based on productive property
so they charged for the apple core
machine in your basement they didn't
charge for the house you're living in
otherwise
they charged for the forge they charged
for the fact that your apple orchard was
doing pretty well versus not very well
at all
and the number of cows you had at one
point they actually added your brain
they said that if you went to Harvard
which I think was the only thing around
at the time and then you um had to pay
for that
on a yearly basis but it seems to have
gone off pretty early I learned that Jim
and a lot of this from Doug Hall who
trained us
my first couple of years on it was
originally a wealth tax
it was based on interest and dividends
this disbursements business didn't exist
in those days but and it was mostly I
think Savings in Banks
but you didn't save in Banks if you were
poor in those days
so um it was a wealth tax
and it was as
most of our taxes were meant to raise
enough money that you could keep running
the state government
so would you be open for another
question I'm not yeah I'm not sure about
the percentage at that point okay
representative plan tables one and two
are those your numbers of dra's numbers
tables one and two oh those are dras
okay
right it's their fiscal note
when you start with on the back with
tables and a table that says estimate
zero zero zero zero because we don't
have any idea what it really is uh and
then gives you some real numbers under
it that's a fiscal note
thank you very much thank you
okay we'll recognize the honorable Gene
ditch former senator
Kawana
thank you and good to see you madam
chair and others my former constituents
um my name is Gene dietch
and I am here because I feel this is a
very important
um
issue I this is my first time back uh in
the last two years or three years
so it's uh I felt it was important
enough to come through the snow
um I've I've also paid the interest in
dividends tax every one of the 38 years
that I've lived here
at least I think so but I oppose well I
support HB 192.
um and I think I have something in
addition to say in addition to
representative almie's uh very extensive
description of the fiscal reasons uh
where why we might need it but mine is
more a description of
um your constituents needs and balancing
the needs of people like myself
versus most of the constituents
um
New Hampshire is losing families if you
look at the first chart
you'll see that according to the Census
Bureau we have gained 47 percent uh
between 2010 and 2020. our senior
population grew by 47 percent which is
significantly above the United States as
a whole
um our working population stayed flat
and we lost children
especially teens and older children
far beyond the level that the rest of
I have a neighbor who's an award-winning
realtor so she has sold some of the most
properties uh recently and she told me
yesterday that almost all her clients
are between the ages of 50 and 70.
that when she does have someone who a
couple who are 30 that they are
childless
this obviously is a problem for the
future of our state
um if we're going to be a state that
makes our uh make us ourselves extremely
attractive to affluent retirees
um that is going to be difficult for the
companies trying to hire
and it's something we need to think
about
so why are we losing families well as as
representative Olney stated we we put an
enormous burden on property taxes even
our businesses I'm a three-time business
owner myself
um I'm so I I think like a business
person and uh property taxes or the rent
paid and the property taxes through the
rent
um are yeah more than what we're paying
BP to BBT
um I believe that these kind and the
problem is of course that salaries
haven't kept up if if salaries were
keeping up with the taxes then we would
have no problem
um people would be able to afford to
live here but they're not
um and they haven't now uh the
wealthiest one percent have gained huge
amounts of wealth since the pandemic uh
the supposedly the
161 billionaires around the world have
doubled their wealth during a time that
um tens of millions of people have slid
into poverty this is
something for the world to be concerned
about but in here in New Hampshire what
that means is that for the same
percentage of wealth half
of the people half of our constituents
your constituents not mine anymore your
constituents
um can buy a 20-piece chicken nugget
and the better off ones uh the 40 above
that
um can pay their utility bill
um
people like me the top 10 percent can
have a two-person vacation in Bermuda
the disparity is is large
and if you turn on the back it shows you
how the breakdown goes this is from New
Hampshire fiscal policy Institute who
wins from the interest in dividends tax
cuts chart on the back you'll see that
almost all of that the money is paid by
uh
a small number of people
and these are the people to whom it
doesn't matter if you think about it if
you thought about your investment
um or my investment in stocks that I get
dividends on
that so I have a say a million dollar
investment in stocks and I get a four
percent return
um which is reasonable return for a
dividend or interest
um then I'm getting forty thousand
dollars and I'm paying five percent of
that that's two dollars on the thousand
okay
now you're going to give wealthy people
who don't need it two dollars on the
thousand tax break
and what are we doing to property tax
owners
we're not giving them that kind of tax
break so my question is who are we
really paying attention to here and who
are we really helping what I think we
need to do and as as you folks did last
year and I thank you very much for it
um is giving the one-time
um uh sharing of Municipal and teacher
pensions
we need to make that permanent again in
2011 they had to they had to drop that I
guess they had to drop it I wasn't there
um because of the recession
but my gosh that's 12 years ago
um here we we say we have all this extra
money we're in such great shape and yet
we're going to cut taxes on the wealthy
so that and not be able to give back
uh the teacher in Municipal pensions
that towns have been having to pay for
12 years
um that doesn't seem right to me and and
the other thing in my town
we have a number of properties that are
deteriorating you know roofs falling in
and so forth and our town clerks or our
town manager says well I can't I can't
take them to court it's too expensive
so these are sitting there deteriorating
because people don't need the money uh
I'm it's you know it's it's it's on a
Excel spreadsheet I've got you know 100
houses on here I'm not paying any
attention that's what happens when you
have stagnant wealth you know you give
two thousand dollar check to me uh on my
you know uh from my cutting the tax you
give me a two thousand dollar check I'm
gonna I'm gonna stow it in my checking
account and it's going to sit there you
give a 200 check to someone who needs it
it's going to go back into the economy
and that two hundred dollars is is going
to go to the grocer and it's going to go
from the grocer to the farmer and from
the farmer to to the person that they
owe money and that's going to be spent
five times and turned into from 200 into
a thousand dollars in the economy
whereas you give it back to someone
who's affluent it just sits there and it
doesn't do anything
so
um I can say that I think that HP 192 is
a good idea it's a good idea to update
the floor in 1976 is a long time ago
and it's a good idea to reinstate the
tax at five percent the people who it
affects will not be seriously affected
and I'm certainly not going to leave New
Hampshire for two thousand dollars
so I thank you very much
uh representative Malloy
thank you thank you for taking uh my
question senator
uh
this this may be
it may not be fair to ask you to answer
this question but what we heard this
morning was
that the GDP in New Hampshire is growing
it's what growing it's increasing it's
been on another subject and and I'm
seeing your uh
chart here today showing the growth in
the population
and seniors and the decline in adults
18 to 64.
uh again this may be an unfair question
but how can we have an increased GDP
with the declining population
I I and again I'm not
I don't want to put anybody it may be
impossible I I don't know you're talking
to someone who used to run an
intelligent robotics company so I can
answer that question very easily
but um it's productivity obviously
um but I think the thing is that looking
at GDP uh is is a very misleading
statistic because GDP is
if if your billionaires are doubling and
well we don't have too many billionaires
in New Hampshire but your 100
millionaires are doubling uh their
wealth
then your average GDP is going to be
going way up but that doesn't mean that
the people who are still getting 12 an
hour or ten dollars an hour are doing
any better and in fact they're doing
thank you very much
um
the chart on the back page of your
handout
uh who wins from interest in dividends
tax cuts
um I'm trying to
catch this in to representative omni's
bill the bill that we're hearing here
and as I
the for maybe you could explain this
chart and how it's How
moving to a higher exemption level as
has been proposed would change this
picture
yes exactly that's a great question
um so uh as you can see from the pi
that's on that chart about 10 percent of
people file we're looking at the chart
um
yeah at the top right hand corner of the
back and the pi on that chart shows that
about 10 percent of people file this tax
and
um so of the 10 percent
well of course I don't know the
particular proportion but about uh
certainly the
11162 are not going to file the 11
063 you're not going to file and uh
about probably about half of the 25 54
so um fewer than half of the people who
know if I would would have to file
follow-up
right
um
so after doing that after taking out all
those taxpayers
how does the chart look
same way as we're looking at it here
yeah yes this is from a few years ago
um oh I didn't write the year I don't
think on here it was from uh New
Hampshire fiscal policy Institute
um
I'm guessing 2020 figures but I'm not
absolutely sure of that so it would have
been at the higher rate
um that was in in place then so the the
figures would look something like they
are now
um
uh
what I want to say was that
[Music]
um
I've sort of Forgotten what I want to
say
um
I'm sorry I forgotten what I was going
to say yeah it looks like we're going to
hear from you on the next bill which is
related topics so we can get back
together yeah but we do have one more
question for you representative orrs
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question so I believe it was
last week Mr Dupree I forget his first
name but he was saying that we have uh
conquered being a resettlement community
that we have many families moving into
the area uh and not only are they moving
into the area there are they're his best
workers so these people are moving in
and I also heard testimony about uh
families in the range of 29 to I think
it was the low 40s moving into New
Hampshire so though our population ages
because we don't have babies born at
zero we have people families moving into
New Hampshire for the recreational
opportunities and they're in the 29 to I
think it was low 40 range so I mean
there seems to be a disconnect
in uh what we heard last week and what
you're sharing with us today can you
maybe expound on that for us
well uh this sounds like case studies
um of good projects
and we want to do more of those
and uh get more of that kind of thing
going on but as far as the overall
statistics uh it's headed in this
direction which which is unfortunate
um but yeah no that's that's very
encouraging news that we'd have some
projects that are working
okay representative fellows has a
question
good afternoon
um I'm new to this committee and so I've
had a lot coming at me all at once
um I had I had always thought of
interest in dividends tax being assessed
on individuals but I have the sense now
that maybe it's not just individuals
there's some some of the payers or the
corporations or something like that uh
corporations that have Investments would
be paying do they pay you know what why
don't we leave that we have the folks
from Dr Ray here and we'll leave some of
that technical questions for them and
they might be able to help us with that
if that's okay okay thank you very much
okay we'll recognize Dennis Hall from
incorrectly on the pink slip but I I am
speaking in opposition to this bill and
I'll save the bulk of my commentary for
the hearing on um the repeal of the
interest of dividends tax but I do want
to say a little bit about rich people
and whether we want them here in New
Hampshire and I believe the answer to
that is unambiguously yes we can save
criticism of billionaires and the entire
capitalistic system for the federal
level where it doesn't matter where the
rich people reside but
people are fleeing California and other
high-tax blue States in droves the top
five states that lost residents in the
last two years are also among the top
six income tax highest income tax states
these people are moving to places like
Florida Arizona Ohio states that do not
have an income tax or have a very low
tax burden
New Hampshire is technically a no-income
tax state but there's always this
asterisk next to
um its name because it taxes interests
and dividends and as as others have
pointed out much of the income and net
worth of of millionaires and
billionaires comes from interest
dividends that they receive on their
stocks and their portfolios so when
they're deciding where to move New
Hampshire is always going to have that
condition attached to it and it's a
disincentive for them to come here they
are the source of a significant part of
the state budget I don't have a number
in mind but they do pay quite a few
taxes here in New Hampshire they move
here they buy houses they pay property
taxes which are the third highest in the
country and it contributes a significant
amount to government revenues I don't
really see a problem with incentivizing
um the wealthy people to move here to
New Hampshire and continue population
growth as hundreds of thousands of
people leave California every year and
these states continue to propose
egregious wealth taxes on top of what
they already have California legislature
is considering a 1.5 percent wealth tax
on the worldwide net worth of all people
making over a billion dollars and in
2026 that threshold will be lowered to
50 million dollars anybody making over
50 million dollars will have to pay 1.5
percent of their entire net worth on top
of a 13 a 13 income tax rate New
Hampshire is the only state in the
Northeast
with
at least a plan to become a no-income
tax state and a state that already does
not tax wages or other income
this is an opportunity for rich people
to move somewhere other than the Sun
Belt the closest the closest state to
New Hampshire with no income tax is
actually Tennessee and this is this is
really more of an opportunity to attract
people who could contribute to higher
government revenues even in a recession
because these people will still have
money and they're not relying on their
wage income and
it doesn't really matter because they're
not relying on employment
um to keep paying their taxes so I just
wanted to point that out and I guess
also that middle and low-class people
are also buying stocks and they're also
receiving dividends and interest on
things like treasury bonds and inflation
bonds which I guess got nine percent a
couple months ago I know quite a few
people myself who are buying these they
don't make a lot of money but
they are also paying taxes
um on stocks and bonds to a degree that
we've never really seen before with the
Advent of platforms like Robinhood and
other ways for ordinary people to buy
stocks and try to protect their income
against the ravages of inflation so I
just wanted to say that um I don't I
don't really see a reason why
um
we should Target wealthy people um with
a reimposition of this interest in
dividends tax when they do have other
options and honestly like more lucrative
options I'm from Florida and I know a
lot of people who prefer to move there
but you know the Northeast is beautiful
and we should incentivize these people
to move here
would you entertain questions
yes
uh over here representative putt yeah
you've made a statement we don't tax
wages what's the business Enterprise tax
isn't that partner taxing wages correct
I should have clarified that the state
is not tax
income or wage income from individuals
the business profits tax obviously would
cover something like that
right representative Phyllis
uh thank you madam chair um I'm having a
hard time understanding your logic
because if we look at this chart we see
that it's
um people with really high income or
people or Corporation or whoever are are
currently paying this tax
why would we want to elim you know why
wouldn't we want to keep this tax so we
get that revenue from them in terms of
your
iron idea that they come here and they
pay property taxes the ultra rep rich
people
are are putting in million multi-million
dollar homes in the towns where there's
ocean Frontage or lake Frontage where
the taxes are the lowest
I just don't and and on top of that
sometimes they buy multiple houses and
they're not even representative is there
a concise question here so I'm just
trying to understand why you have your
position giving given that rationale I
just I'm not seeing how that benefits
New Hampshire at all well 62 percent of
New Hampshire's population growth is due
to migration from other states and when
we see such historic numbers of people
coming from high-tech States and moving
to states with no income tax the
interest in dividends prevents it
presents a serious obstacle in their
decision-making process
um and even if they do buy a house in a
place with relatively low property taxes
um but I believe State Property Tax
collections are still you know among the
top three in the nation and they're
paying taxes on anything that they buy
in the state which then contributes to
business property business profits tax
revenue which is taxed at a rate of 7.6
and um
I believe that this money is something
that
the state should incentivize
um to flow here rather than to other
no-income tax states that don't have
that condition on interest and dividends
which does constitute a pretty
significant portion of
we've established in earlier testimony
that um
this tax that we're talking about now
the interest in dividends tax has been
around for a very long time it's one of
you've spoken about how you think this
tax disincentivizes people
with lots of money to
migrate to New Hampshire but you've also
spoken about how they are migrating to
New Hampshire
apparently
even though we've had a five percent
interest in dividends tax on the books
throughout this
relevant period of time perhaps for the
last hundred years or more
um what evidence do you have that it's
operating as a disincentive for people
who pay would if they can't Came Here
Pay significant interest in dividends
tax
I don't know if there's a way to draw
this connection using actual numbers and
evidence I would say that New Hampshire
does not rank among the top states that
people are moving to from States like
California or pretty much anywhere else
I believe the population growth is on a
decline somewhat 11 000 people or so
last year but these people are still
moving in droves from places like
California which lost I believe 130 000
people last year and the true no income
tax states remain far ahead of New
Hampshire in terms of population growth
and where these people are moving to
from the blue States and I believe
eliminating this particular obstacle
could contribute somewhat to making New
Hampshire just as an attractive of an
opportunity as Florida or Texas or
Arizona or any of these other places
that are so far away and honestly just
don't have many of the benefits in terms
of new in terms of just New Hampshire
New Hampshire's natural beauty being in
the Northeast all of these other things
I believe that this could provide some
sort of incentive I don't know if you
could actually track that over time and
see you know you'd have to survey
somebody and say why are you moving to
New Hampshire for this reason but it
would be an ideal way to continue
population growth as we continue to see
people moving in record numbers from
states that are the highest taxes in the
nation clearly that's a driving factor
in why these people are moving and if
they don't want to pay any income taxes
they would look at this interest in
dividends tax and say well I still have
to pay five percent every year on this I
don't have to do that in States like
Florida or South Carolina or states that
are even moving to a no income tax such
as Iowa Kentucky Mississippi Georgia
um and States like that so it would put
New Hampshire
um on a competitive level with the rest
of these states that are seeing this
kind of massive growth
thank you very much appreciate it okay
we'll recognize Catherine I'm gonna kill
it again Lao head from tax Foundation
thank you madam chair and members of the
committee again my name is Catherine
lawhead I'm with the tax foundation in
Washington DC and once again we do not
take a position on legislation but I
would like to share some information
about this bill and the impacts that
would have
um as you know House Bill 192 would
repeal the planned phase out of the
interest in dividends tax and increase
the rate back up to five percent
and it would also increase the interest
in dividends tax exemption from two
thousand four hundred dollars to seven
thousand five hundred dollars and the
additional exemption for taxpayers who
are 65 or older blind or disabled would
be increased from one thousand two
hundred to three thousand five hundred
dollars
now phasing out the tax on interest and
dividends income as New Hampshire is in
the process of doing
would cause New Hampshire to join the
ranks of the seven other states that
forego in individual income tax entirely
so there's very little justification
right now given the current budget
surplus and given the state's historic
Revenue growth
to do away with a plan to phase out this
tax over time
in particular increasing the events the
interest in dividends tax rate while
increasing the associated exemptions as
this bill would do would actually narrow
the tax base while increasing their rate
which is generally the opposite of what
good tax policy tries to do generally a
broader base and a lower rate generates
a Stabler source of Revenue and is a
more preferable tax structure
but increasing the rate while increasing
the exemption would place would shift a
larger amount of the tax burden onto a
smaller subset of the population
if New Hampshire truly does find itself
in a revenue bind in the future which it
is not in currently but if that is the
case in the future there are better
sources of revenue to turn to than the
interest in dividends tax uh such as the
business Enterprise tax which as I
mentioned earlier is a very stable
source of Revenue compared to some of
the other taxes New Hampshire levies
additionally the tax on real property is
a highly stable source of Revenue and
that can help the state whether economic
downturns quite well
over the past decade the states that
forego and individual income tax have
seen their populations grow at twice the
national rate and this is really
something New Hampshire could uh benefit
from as well especially in an era where
there's increased workplace flexibility
and a lot of people are able to have
hybrid or completely remote work
environments
a lot of people are looking to move to
places where they the cost of living
cost of living and the tax burden is
relatively lower so New Hampshire should
look to take advantage of that I'll also
mention that a lot of the burden of this
tax does fall on not just the wealthy
but on everyday citizens including lower
and middle income people who do have
investment portfolios and have you know
pensions or 401K plans and other
Investments that this tax would fall on
so by allowing folks to keep more of the
return on their Investments they will
have more money to spend and save as
they see fit and they will have more
money to reinvest in the state's economy
so with that I am happy to answer any
questions
I don't see any hands up so thank you
very much thank you
okay and now we have the dra here uh
Lauren O'Sullivan and Wendy metivier
would you want to come up and maybe help
would you care to summarize what you're
handing out
or so good afternoon I'm I'm Lauren
O'Sullivan from the Department of
Revenue Administration and with me I
have Wendy matibir financial analyst
with dra
and we do not have a position on this
bill we're here to answer questions what
I'm handing out today is just a um it's
just a fiscal guide to help basically
summarize the fiscal note that you've
and we are available for any questions
I think the question I kept hearing and
then I'll recognize you
um
who pays this tax could you help us
really understand is it businesses or is
it more individuals when is it paid like
how often thank you I know it would have
been really helpful on Monday if we had
the presentation
so so a quick overview of the tax it's
currently a four percent on interest in
dividends income for taxable periods
ending on or after 12 31 2023
um who's subject to the tax all New
Hampshire residents fiduciaries llc's
Partnerships and associations with
income from interest and dividends
and um when when to file for our
calendar year filers the returns are due
on April 15th and there's also seventh
seven month extensions to file with
payment and are due by the return date
and estimates are equal to 25 percent of
the estimated tax and they're either due
on April 15th June 15th September 15th
or January 15th
if the estimated liability exceeds five
hundred dollars
that will not that is not in the note
that will be in the presentation
um I believe in February
yeah
okay uh representative rosenford had a
question and then we'll go to
representative ulrey yes thank you madam
chair thank you
um and I'm looking at this and I
compared it to the fiscal note that was
uh in the bill the same the table two
just so I'm understanding this properly
and I may not be so please forgive me
um the way I'm reading this and the way
I'm interpreting this if we were to if
this bill were to pass
uh HB 192 were to be enacted into law
I'm looking at that table two
then we would then be levying an
additional
116 million dollars a year in taxes by
am I reading that right
that that's right when compared to the
current law which has the phase out to
zero percent okay it's not additional
it's it's maintaining
but but if but the way it is now the law
may follow up
so so the way it is now as of you know
today the law is the the we're scheduled
to phase out correct so that
but if we were to pass this 192 we're
essentially not phasing it out so we
were then adding 116 million dollars in
taxes yeah I went cramped like that yes
representative ulery first and then
representative Ames
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question if I heard you
correctly you you
mentioned llc's Etc
as paying this tax
uh if they receive more than that seven
thousand five hundred dollars in
interest and dividend
s
let's say the threshold on the income is
twenty four hundred twenty four hundred
first single file I earned 4 800 for
joint okay follow up Madam chair
so essentially then that this if this
goes back into effect
you're taxing small businesses an
over what they're paying now so this is
the tax on
the heart spread of
New Hampshire businesses small
businesses LLCs individual practitioners
doctors chiropractors uh uh pharmacists
or independent uh pharmacists that uh
formulary pharmacists not CVS and
Walgreens that's a different area
uh
any business that moderately successful
in making a little bit of money have I
got that correct
well the the IND tax
um the composition of the tax is on
interest dividends federal tax exempt
interest and distributions so that's
what would be subject to the tax
so well one final follow-up just to make
final follow-up see how this goes thank
you and I appreciate the forbearance
Madam chair and members thank you uh so
they make the money they put in their
Savings in uh for their retirement and
instead of being
deferred such as a Roth IRA will it be
deferred or a regular Ira even with
required minimum distribution would be
uh
deferred at a lower uh lower tax rate
they could hit with the full thing when
they start taking money out is that
correct
I'll have to get back to you on that
thank you
okay representative Ames did you have a
question no okay anything over on this
side
okay and a reminder that we will have
more agency presentations coming and
especially from the dra and we will do
okay are there any other folks who would
like to speak on House Bill 192.
seeing none we will close the public
hearing
so the question was asked how are we
handing the blue sheet information I
don't have a researcher sitting there to
tell us we also don't know at the moment
who has logged in to the general court
website and maybe testified through the
portal I'm trying to learn that and I've
got our assistant Karen working on that
to figure out how do we get that there
is a link on the general court website
that says View House online testimony
submissions
she did not tell me how to get there
though so as soon as we see someone
we'll we'll ask them that question
um representative orrs do you would you
want to see if you can see if there's a
clipboard with a blue sheet on House
Bill 192.
good
foreign
yes okay thank you thank you so much
okay we do have a blue sheet on this
bill
and let's see one two three four five
six seven people signed in
two for it one two three four five
against
um
hmm
and it's now two o'clock so we will now
open the public hearing on House Bill
100 to repeal the interest and dividends
tax
and thank you I may actually be a
co-sponsor on this one so for the record
and we will now recognize the prime
sponsor representative janigian to
introduce the bill
thank you madam chair
I am representative John janegian
Rockingham District 25 which is Salem
so HB 100
we already have the interest in
dividends taxed as most of you probably
known or if you don't will be phased out
as of January 1st 2027.
so this bill HP 100 what it does is
proposes accelerating that phase out
to January 1st 2024.
foreign
New Hampshire we basically tout
ourselves as uh income tax-free State
however the one asterisk as I think has
been mentioned uh previously actually
two states had that asterisk Tennessee
and New Hampshire both income income
tax-free States however taxing interest
and dividends
so Tennessee has now removed their
interest in dividends tax so New
Hampshire is the only one left now with
the asterisk
um
so this again this bill proposes to
phase out the interest in dividends tax
um by January 1st 2024.
what are the advantages of of doing this
obviously there's there's been a lot of
talk about should we be doing this
what's the effect of it we're worrying
about potential recession
but the one thing that that happens a
lot of times with tax policy it's always
looked at as though it was a static
thing if we reduce this tax by this much
then we lose this much but nothing in
life is static everything's Dynamic
there's all sorts of interactions going
on
in various ways so
first off
one of the things and it's been
mentioned before but and it's one of my
points so I had already added down but
we want to stop the migration of wealthy
individuals once they retire out of New
Hampshire and from New Hampshire a lot
of them are going to Florida you know we
a lot of States like New York and
California are losing people to other
states usually not New Hampshire
although as a side comment which I don't
have on this sheet
I do have some income property and I am
a pair of this of this tax but um two of
my most recent tenants are in the 25 to
30 year old range both moving out of New
York to escape high taxes now neither of
these guys are just starting out they're
not paying interest in dividends tax but
they're thinking about the future they
like the fact of the the the tax
lowering tax lower taxes in New
Hampshire as well as when they think
about you know later years
so I think it can have an effect on on
younger people as well
um
the I I believe eliminating the interest
in dividends tax and this is where we
can't think about things as just being
static right is will most likely lead to
higher business profits taxes and the
reason for that is that
many um and I believe it's dra can can
correct me here but many of the llc's
corporations with transferable shares
have to pay those individuals have to
pay a tax on their distributions of of
profit and that is treated as a dividend
so they're paying a five percent tax on
that that's five percent less money that
can go into
uh you know building the business paying
employees
investing in the future of the business
paying higher wages to employees all
sorts of things again we have to keep
thinking about the dynamic nature of
this and not get caught up in just the
static nature of reducing attacks
um
the other thing that I believe would
happen is people will migrate oh we
already know this people are migrating
to states with lower taxes and
while we are getting some people
migraines to New Hampshire we are losing
out on the high net worth people and I
I'll disagree with a speaker from a
previous bill I heard where when you get
when wealthy get extra money they just
put it in the bank I I strongly disagree
with that wealthy people don't focus on
just putting money in a bank and letting
it sit there they want to expand that
money they're going to invest it in
businesses and the more people wealthy
people we have in New Hampshire the more
likely they are to invest in New
Hampshire businesses and many of them
are business owners and they may in fact
bring their business from another state
to New Hampshire so I don't think we
want to overlook that potential
and then you know we we do know that a
lot of older people retirees are paying
the interest in dividends tax no matter
what their level is as long as they're
above the um
the uh the minimum deduction and so it's
not fair that that elderly elderly and
retired are paying a larger burden
um of their taxes because of that
um
and I guess I already I already made my
last Point
um that uh with the elimination of
attacks more wealthy are likely to come
to the state so those are the reasons I
believe that while when you look at the
fiscal note it may look like a large
number there I don't believe that's
going to be the final that's a static
number that's a static result of just
reducing it without looking at all these
positives that will happen increasing
which will increase actually the BET tax
the BPT tax and I believe increased
investment in businesses which will also
result in Greater growth for New
Hampshire and higher business profits
taxes thank you and I'll take any
questions
representative fellows then
representative Almy
thank you
I was wondering if you can I'm having
such a hard time getting a understanding
of who pays the tax
um you mentioned corporations with
transferable shares can can you just
give me like a hypothetical example of
like what kind of company is that a
hedge fund or what what kind of company
is that and what might be going on yeah
I mean I'm not an expert in tax policy
and dra can probably answer this but for
example there an example of
non-transferable shares would be like
somebody starts an LLC they've got a
couple members three members whatever
they can't just sell a portion of that I
believe they they have to actually
dissolve the LLC you can't change the
ownership easily so a company with
transferable shares is set up such that
you can sell you know a certain
percentage of that company to another
individual and then they can become a
shareholder so it's all those companies
uh where the llc's ins you know
incorporate the companies
um
there are Partnerships with transferable
shares so it just depends on the setup
but all those companies when they
distribute their profits to their
shareholders those shareholders have to
pay the interest and dividends tax so
you could think of it as a portion of
that money which could you know Partners
don't just again take their money and
put it in the bank I mean somebody might
but typically they're investing in other
things maybe they're investing it back
in that business or they're investing in
other businesses and this is what I mean
by there's a dynamic interaction here
and it's not it's not just static
thank you that's the closest I've got to
thank you
on this is an extraordinarily difficult
area and there have been studies on both
sides
about people migrating uh away from
high-tech States and people not
migrating away from high-tech States the
demographer let the last two times he
came in said that more low-income people
than higher income people leave New
Hampshire
I've just wanted to see what you
you think of these numbers
um I guess the rest of it would be
something I am going to have to say at
Great Lengths when we get to the to the
um
yeah I would just remind the members of
the committee that this is our time to
hear from the public or the sponsor and
to ask clarifying questions on what the
intent of the bill is what the rationale
was maybe the data that they have
obviously what the executive session
we'll all get to say are little speeches
about how we feel about the policy so
we'll have a chance to do that later uh
are there any more questions for or did
you want to try to answer that or
take it under advisement
uh we'll take that under advisement
because I I can talk I can talk
generally on how I feel on that but I'd
rather talk about actual data thank you
excellent yes
can you turn on your mic so everyone can
hear you
can we please have a work session on
this rather than
just the executive session after we've
all made our minds up
I will take that under advisement thank
you thank you oh representative orrs
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question so earlier you
mentioned that the dra could probably
give us a better example of where these
numbers would fall because if I
understood what you said correctly if we
eliminate I and D we're probably going
to make money back through the business
profit tax is that correct so follow-up
question so
who would give us those kind of
estimates what what agency what group
what organization in New Hampshire gives
us those estimates
well I don't know presumably dra but but
exactly that that's what I thought and
and so my question is why is it that we
are hearing from the dra they obviously
are bipartisan
but they can never give us an estimate
whether any of these uh positions are
going to be uh raising the tax or
lowering the tax well I'll let the dra
answer that but my understanding is that
the the it's very hard to put together
an absolute Dynamic model so the models
are based on static you know you reduce
it by this much here's how much you lose
I so I don't know what the future of
creating Dynamic models are or whether
they have a better answer than I just
gave you okay thank you very much thank
you madam chair thank you representative
okay we will now recognize former Vice
chair of this committee representative
Patrick Obama who is also here
and I'm joined by Dan McGuire who's also
here from Granite State
representative Maguire could you also
give a giving card at some point thank
you so much
you can sit together if that works
whatever whatever works for you guys
well it's good to be back in ways of
means good to have you guys back
an hour ago I was downstairs testifying
I was on the somehow I got wrangled and
being on the rear-facing car seat
chairing the rear-facing car seat
committee with the Senate of uh and uh
I actually wrote the final report so I
figured I'd better go down there and
present the report to this Committee in
the Senate so it's good to be back uh
since I've left you uh the Granite City
taxpayers approached me to be on their
board so I'm wearing that hat but I hope
the chair will give me a little latitude
to also wear my other hat the private
citizen had in my knowledge of ways and
means
uh the Granite City taxpayers
overwhelmingly support uh house bill
100. and do not support House Bill 192
which would be reversed last year's or
uh movement towards elimination of
interest and dividends tax
oh representative fellows just left I'll
wait hope this gets back while I'm still
talking uh do we think she left because
I have an answer to her question
about an example and some of you who
have been in ways of means for a while I
I was a owner of a company in
Massachusetts uh which was an S corp
and when I moved to New Hampshire we
discovered that every distribution that
we would get to either take profit out
of the company or to pay federal taxes
I was New Hampshire recognized that as a
dividend and I had to pay five percent
every time I did it got a distribution
to New Hampshire
uh so this that would go away that's
that's an example of what I think
Department of sponsor was trying to
trying to bring out
the thing I hope that the committee does
is view this this particular bill in
regard to the other well I would say out
of two tax cut bills that you heard this
morning uh House Bill 15 moving the BET
from 0.55 to 0.5 and the uh uh house
house bill 133 communication Services
tax
because when I looked at the fiscal
reports with notes at least the ones
with the bills not the updated ones we
were talking in 24 combined all those
three of 62.5 million reduction
uh for 24 and in 25
135.6 million dollar reduction in
revenues in those two fiscal years
so we can't view this bill in isolation
we have to view it in in looking at the
other tax reduction bills at the same
time
uh I I certainly support and I this is
where I want a little attitude just to
say that I I do support uh the uh to be
bet reduction uh the granite state
hasn't taken a position on it that we
were told to testify on
and then there's the uh so the uh the
Communication Service tax bill
which I have some hesitation on to be
honest with you and the reason I have
hesitation on that one is we can't strip
away all our tax base
uh because the beauty of New Hampshire
is taxes is that we have a broad base of
taxes that buffer us from recession up
and down
we tend to have a less of a of a decline
in a recession and a quicker return
after a recession because of the spread
of the taxes that we have
so I I would caution on the
telecommunity that's 30 million dollars
uh it's a couple bucks and everybody's
telephone bill
uh just for the for the uh the voice
part not not the uh not the data part so
uh that's just my two cents there
uh
the uh by the way
our our treasury
loves in our our bond rating agencies
loves the fact that we have a broad base
of taxes to to work from uh we always
rate very high uh we we have good good
Bond ratings and and they also like the
fact that we have a robust rainy day
fund
so
uh
I'm so I'm assuming that all these bills
are not early bills
I'm assuming that it's just a ways it
means Bell so you don't have to exec
these right away if you don't want to
I and I know you're in the middle of of
looking at revenues and we've had a good
we've had a good run the last two years
no question about it I mean where are we
are well above Target you know last year
411 million
uh totaled 249 million just for the
business taxes
and and this year to date including
through yesterday we're up uh 236
million for all taxes and 145 million
from business taxes so it continues
and the beauty of our business taxes
is that you know the reason I really
support moving the point five to the
point five is that was our plan all
along and there's no question in my mind
that
that the the amount of Revenue we're
getting on our business tax revenues
with reduced taxes is clear that we've
attracted businesses here that are truly
turning out uh a lot of profits that are
turning into tax revenue for us
so but I know you're faced with as you
do your revenues
uh
there's you have to determine how far is
it going to be a recession or not
to me we're partly in it already
uh measure the impact of housing sales
which have slowed although prices have
stayed High
uh impact of Massachusetts passing uh
sports betting
on on lottery
I was just chatting with someone
yesterday about this and there's some
concern there
uh then obviously we have to understand
the impact of single sales factor that
we move to
uh uh despite Ways and Means house ways
it means objections
uh
then of course there's the
um the lowering of the allowable credit
carry forward for some of the new
members I don't know if you guys have
already talked about this uh that you
know the credit carry forward is an
issue we're not quite sure what that's
going to amount to
uh that we start writing checks back to
companies
who who who don't want the money they
want to keep the money they want us to
keep the money but we're forcing them to
take the money back
so
with that all said I would I do support
this uh but I would
I would because my two cents Mr Madam
chair
uh you don't have to execute these right
away you can see what the revenue
numbers look like as you once you get
through your process of Revenue
projecting and then you can make the
calls down as to which of these you want
to want to act on but I do support the
the reduction in this Bill thank you
thank you representative McGuire do you
want to go ahead and then we'll do a
quick round of questions thank you
absolutely thank you very much Madam
chair members of the committee for the
record my name is Dan McGuire I'm here
represented Granite Granite State
taxpayers
um this committee's loss has been our
gain with Pat here
um we have long maintained that the
interest in dividends tax is the worst
tax that we have in terms of uh
economics it's the most economically
destructive tax we have so there are a
lot of different taxes and we all know
that when you tax something you get less
of it so some taxes that's deliberate
right like the cigarette tax tobacco tax
for example it's a good thing that there
are less smoking because of that tax
right that's deliberate there's other
things the communication tax maybe
there's a little bit less use of
communication maybe it doesn't make much
difference
and
so consumption taxes are not so
economically destructive they they work
a little against that particular area so
things like the rooms and meal stacks
and so on there's a little bit less
rental income there's a little bit less
restaurant meals and so on because of
that tax but overall in the economy it
doesn't make that much of a difference
but by comparison to the interest in
dividend taxes the interest in dividends
tax is is a direct tax on investment and
savings
and investment in savings are what makes
the future better than today
right so in order to to be economically
in better shape tomorrow
we need investment and savings today
investment in savings by his capital
capital and cruise improves productivity
productivity means higher standard of
living
so without any you know if they're ABS
you know if if absolutely everything
created was consumed then tomorrow at
best could be equal to today right
except that things wear out and so on
but but if we have savings if we have
investment that's what makes tomorrow
better than today and and in an economic
sense that is human happiness that's you
know having a better tomorrow than today
is what makes people happier and so on
right so so it's that this tax is is
restricting something that we that we
want to we would rather encourage right
I mean it's almost like
you'd want to match somebody's sayings
in an investment rather than tax it all
right because it's that important to the
economy so
um so this tax is the one if you if
there's any one tax you're going to be
able to cut this year
uh in our mind this is it thank you
uh representative all me no I've got a
question for
The Honorable abrami uh this I keep
hearing this thing about we come out of
recessions quicker
than other states we never thought that
before do you have any data on this
I've heard that many times in ways and
means that we've come out of recessions
faster
on would that be the gross domestic
product or something it's following the
revenues
because we don't have an income tax with
sales tax
which makes us different than other
states other states get impacted more by
recessions because of the broad-based
taxes that they have that's usually the
driver and we're we're impacted less
because that when this recession less
people are working less less income tax
people are buying less less sales tax we
don't we have those buffers because we
don't have those taxes we have other
taxes that are there people won't give
up their phones for instance I mean Most
states have telecommunication taxes as
well
but we we are protected by the uh the
way our our taxes are are structured in
such a way that that we we just don't
get impacted as much by recession as
other states
representative Schoenberg Schamberg has
could I comment on that question
thank you madam chair so
um I used to live uh in Washington state
near Oregon those states are are uh
heavily affected because they have they
have very large specific Employers in
Washington state it's Microsoft and
Boeing in Oregon it's Intel and so and
so a recession that hurts those
particular employers puts a huge Downer
on those particular States New Hampshire
doesn't have that sort of thing New
Hampshire has a lot of very of small and
medium businesses they don't have a
dominant employer in the same way and so
you know if this one is affected a
little bit that one might not be and so
and so so we have a much more even
keeled economy I think than than many
other states which have those kind of
big dominant businesses
representative Schamberg and then
representative ulery
thank you madam chair
I will ask for a second question here
depending on their answer on the first
one
uh
either one of you could answer this
um
when you have an LLC
so in this particular case I I think
Pat was right that that the
distributions from an LLC come under
this tax okay um
and I don't know I guess I'm not as well
I don't know bptvt well enough to to
comment on that one do you yeah yeah
if there's no other taxes paid bet or
BPT
how
does an LLC support our infrastructure
Market if they're not taxed at all from
roads electronic electricity uh
just our Marketplace
other than hiring people I guess but
I mean there's a reason why we have the
bet I mean to keep pet came in place for
the for the sole Proprietors and for the
LLCs
I mean was cabletron that that was the
one that complained years ago that well
these guys aren't paying any tax so we
put the bet in place which is a tax on
the number of employees you have
uh and and then you know if you make a
profit that's fine
but you know they offset each other and
all that so so llc's are paying taxes
under the bet
my understanding yeah and that may not
be a question they can answer fully
depending on the type of LLC they have I
could answer that at a further time but
we don't want to interrupt this public
hearing on this but we want to stay
focused please on this particular Bill
and what it does representative uh
Oliveri had a question and then
representative orrs thanks
thank you and uh belated happy birthday
representative not too far off yeah
um
I'm trying to understand what you said
you had a corporation in Massachusetts
an escort yes which is a limited
Corporation right
and when it came time to pay taxes
you made a withdrawal in order to pay
taxes
okay and oh
if if that was the case
you were being taxed on the withdrawal
so you were paying the tax to pay a tax
yeah so an S corp all your taxes flow
through your personal income tax first
off okay
so what we do in Mike we did an old as
Corps stews if you had to pay federal
tax let's say quarterly we would give
ourselves distribution
to that would flow to me into my
personal account and then I would pay my
taxes
and we have a we had a tax attorney that
followed the letter of the law he has to
report that to New Hampshire
that that there was a distribution
because I lived in New Hampshire of
course I lived in New Hampshire that
that was the that was the problem
so I would have to turn around and write
a quarterly payment
of of my uh of that uh
from that transaction to the dra every
quarter
to to meet our requirements so yes that
happens now we had a bill years ago and
we hadn't built recently too
that tried to fix it's a quirk it was
one of our many quirks in in our tax
code
and be honest with you we did the dra
did the math
and they at the time they said to fix
this problem it was all it would be a
big negative to the revenues of
of
New Hampshire
even I voted against the bill because it
was it would have helped me this bill
would have helped me and I you know and
then we had a similar Bill a couple
years ago didn't go anywhere
but this would solve the problem because
the the whole that whole tax will be
gone so
but again it was it was as described at
the time as a court of our policy was
recognized as an issue uh that needed to
be fixed and we never fixed it
uh no representative orrs had a question
I would like to make sure that everyone
gets a first round of questions first
and then we can go back for a second if
we need
thank you madam chair my question just
representative liebly
thank you madam chair for taking my
question
um so there's an implication in the
story you shared with us and I just
wanted to make sure I understood the
implication correctly so when you moved
from Massachusetts up to New Hampshire
and you had to pay the IND tax when you
took a disbursement
the implication is that that was more
taxes than you had paid in Massachusetts
is that am I
did I interpret that my partners my
other partners didn't have to pay
Massachusetts then because they lived in
Massachusetts
I mean I I was the only one I was the
only five Partners I was the only one
that lived in New Hampshire
did you have
on your business
oh yes I also had to pay I had to pay
prop uh uh yes I had to pay income taxes
in
I had to pay personal income taxes in
Massachusetts as well
but this is not an income this was this
was a so did your taxes go up when you
moved to New Hampshire is that oh yeah
net although we're down the happy part
of the story is that my partner is
recognizing this
kept me whole
they would they would basically up they
gave me a greater payment
in the distribution time they marked it
up so that because then knowing that I
had to pay tax to New Hampshire so they
kept me hold they didn't have to do that
thank you okay
okay first round of questions good okay
is there a second round of questions
not at this time I don't think okay
great thank you guys
okay uh we'll recognize Gene dish again
um and
Senator if I know you already covered a
lot of these talking points in the last
bill if you could keep it to new
my name my name is Gene dietch uh German
name uh the second vowel determines the
sound
um
well you know uh you know that I'm
opposed to 100
um because I feel that this puts the
emphasis in the wrong direction again I
I think we're given two dollars per
thousand uh to the affluent and we
really need
um now I appreciate uh representative
guanami's
um uh suggestion that we wait and look
at the overall view rather than rushing
at any of these bills and and because
it's really the total picture that
counts so I've heard that uh you know we
come out of recession faster but if we
come into a recession faster why did we
not reinstate
the teacher Municipal pensions that we
cut in 2011 because of the recession you
know to me that's not uh coming out of
recession and when uh
what we've listened to is the issues
from a business point of view and I
understand those as I say I've I've run
three businesses I sold one
to a to a public company
but
um
we're not looking at the real facts
we've got these young people who are
coming up in here hypothetically saying
oh well I think people are are moving to
low-tech States uh and that that's the
reason we're moving out you can look at
the census data and the Census Data
actually shows uh what's happening okay
you can hypothesize that people are
leaving California faster and going to
Tennessee or wherever but I can tell you
why people are moving from New Hampshire
to Florida and you can look out the
window and see it right there
okay it's not because of the IND text
um
I I think we need to look at both sides
yes there there are impacts on business
but you know
um I was reading a Wall Street Journal
report the other day that said the uh
ballooning stock prices were really the
result of pushing all this more money to
the to the wealthy uh to the
billionaires at the bottom uh you push
that money in and they have nowhere to
put it
the the stock prices go up because
that's what there is to invest in so
when there's more money floating around
it uh it uh inflates the stock prices
and we've seen what happens after the
balloon is is burst
um that's not real gain and when
companies as what happened when the
stock prices are up when companies are
not investing in r d when they are not
investing in equipment but they are
buying back stock
that's an indication that you've got a
bubble and you are not through tax
policy and giving them more money
creating more wealth in the future so
it's not something that always happens
yes if if if uh if companies are short
of money
um and uh and we give them incentives
for r d
instead of incentives to give money back
to shareholders
you know these are two things
um and actually back in the days of very
high
um uh taxes you know back in the 90
percent uh uh tax uh income tax
categories there was more money going
into our Indian equipment and so forth
because the owners didn't take it out of
the company they wanted to put it into
something that would create future
growth so it's it's not something that
you can just continue doing the same
thing over and over uh forever and it
always is good we balance okay you you
you put some money back in you take some
money out in taxes and put it into
infrastructure it's all a balance and
we're out of balance right now
the country is way out of balance and we
see that in in the number of
billionaires and their increasing wealth
so what I'm suggesting is that we pay
attention to those people that is it
always better to have a broad-based tax
for everything is it always better to
take two dollars per thousand and give
it back to the affluent instead of
giving that back to towns so that they
can take care so that the people there
don't have to increase their property
taxes you know people have talked about
they want more people to move into the
state where are we gonna put them we got
new houses
I mean really yeah uh we we could not
possibly have the kind of influx that
um Colorado was having or or that uh
Florida's having we don't have anywhere
for them to go so you know it's and the
reason we don't have anywhere for them
to go is because the cost of building
houses and and many other factors you
know too much to get into
but the other thing I think we need to
realize is that
having a larger poor population
costs money
we all know that right Health and Human
Services has to pay more
we know that our special edu Ed
population goes up we've got all kinds
of kids we have children of of addicts
um you know coming into the schools I
can tell you the kids the teachers
in the conville district are being hit
and bitten
I this these kinds of problems have have
increased dramatically we have greater
child poverty than we used to much more
we really need to pay attention to the
other to our constituents most of our
constituents or your constituents
um and these these people are important
too and uh honestly
um you know of all the people who are
here I I certainly am someone who is
going to continue to pay the tax if you
pass 192. and I am willing to pay the
tax because I think it will make my
future and my society and New Hampshire
better
thank you very much
not a question but uh I just wanted for
the record since it was pointed out that
representative fellows wasn't here
earlier on she had to leave for another
hearing where she's the prime sponsor of
a bill I wanted that on the record and
um yeah after we get through the public
hearing we'll chat as a committee on
next steps okay
okay we have Catherine lauhead again
from the text Foundation she has a busy
day here today
foreign
thank you again Madam chair and members
of the committee my name is Catherine
lawhead with the tax foundation and I'll
be testifying in a neutral capacity on
House Bill 100.
as you know the phase out of the
interest and dividends tax uh began with
the enactment in June of 2021 of the
current biennial budget and Implement
implementation of that phase out began
this month with the rate dropping from 5
in 2022 to 4 in 2023 and this
legislation would repeal the tax three
years earlier than initially planned
with repeal taking place next January
1st instead of January 1st 2027
as a result this legislation would not
only end the tax three years earlier
than planned but it would also allow
taxpayers to keep more of the Returns on
their Investments allowing them to have
more of that money to reinvest in the
economy
but in addition to the tax savings they
would receive this bill would also spare
taxpayers the burden of three additional
years of filing income tax forms in New
Hampshire
given that policy makers have already
agreed to phase out the interest in
dividends tax it makes sense that this
body would also work to expedite that
phase out to the extent the state has
Revenue capacity to do so
if the int if the IND tax had already
been repealed New Hampshire would rank
7th instead of ninth on the state
business tax climate index's individual
tax component and New Hampshire would
rank fifth overall instead of sixth in
terms of the overall competitiveness of
the state's tax structure so that is
definitely something the state can look
forward to once the tax is phased out
this tax is of course the one policy
that is standing in the way of New
Hampshire truly joining the ranks of the
other seven income tax free states and
as has been noted earlier today on
income tax maps and analyzes that my
organization and others produce New
Hampshire does continue to receive an
asterisk denoting that the state does
not tax wage and salary income but does
continued attacks interest in dividends
income
now Most states that do have individual
income taxes do apply that same rate or
rates to in interest in dividends income
so New Hampshire is now unique among
states in applying a tax specifically to
interest and dividends but not to wage
and salary income
for many years both New Hampshire and
Tennessee received asterisks because
both States uh or because Tennessee was
one of the states that used to Levy
attacks on interest in dividends income
only that was known as the hall tax that
was phased out by one percentage Point
per year reduced from six percent in
2015 to 1 in 2020 and then repealed
entirely in January of 2021
and as a source of Revenue this tax in
New Hampshire is particularly unstable
because revenues are tied to the
performance of the stock market so the
tax will naturally bring in much more
money when the economy is doing well
than when it is doing poorly
this tax is also a relatively small
source of overall revenue for the state
bringing in only about
156.4 million dollars in fiscal year
so that amounts to about seven percent
of New Hampshire's tax collections for
that year
the fiscal note for the bill specifies
that repealing the tax in 2024 would
yield approximately
187.6 million dollars worth of tax
savings to taxpayers spread out over
multiple years comparing compared to the
current plan of phasing out the tax by
one percentage Point per year
and Expediting that phase out would of
course benefit taxpayers but giving
ongoing economic uncertainty and a bit
of a slowing down of Revenue growth it
would be wise for policy makers to take
a close look at Revenue projections to
ensure Expediting the phase out can be
accomplished responsibly but to the
extent it could this is definitely a tax
that is one of the more harmful in New
Hampshire and is one of the taxes most
worthy of being phased out
so in short this tax would or Expediting
Expediting the phase out would reduce
tax and compliance burdens for New
Hampshire residents and it would also
reduce administrative costs for the
state and improve the competitiveness of
New Hampshire's tax structure so this is
a policy change that is well worth
considering and I'm happy to take any
questions
representative only
thank you
has the tax Foundation done any research
on the percentage of wealthy people that
um earn considerable amounts by
investment on who are investing
[Music]
actively and directly in businesses
and likely maybe to be in doing that
business here though that doesn't always
happen either uh
as versus the ones who like me just put
it in mutual funds
and we have no idea where it goes but
I'm pretty sure very little of it stays
in New Hampshire thank you
we haven't done a study of that nature
that's a little bit outside of our scope
but
um again I think you know interest in
dividends taxes are something that
people pay regardless of how much income
they earn so if you do have above the
basic amount of Investments uh you're
going to be subject to this tax and so
that results in reduced investment you
know less income to invest back in these
businesses and back in you know
consumption or other things that will
representative roachford
yes thank you madam chair just looking
at your handout your third bullet point
just curious
um when you say New Hampshire would rank
seventh instead of ninth and then fifth
instead of six overall who who is ahead
of us
what states are ahead of us as far as
tax
the top two are I believe I believe
Wyoming and South Dakota are slightly
ahead I will have to get you that exact
list but usually the state's in the top
ten are
do not Levy one of the major taxes so
that does apply to New Hampshire you
know normally if you don't have a tax
you're going to rank first overall on
that component of our index so uh New
Hampshire I believe ranks first for
sales taxes tied with other states that
don't have a sales tax by virtue of that
so that helps bring up the state's
overall score but you do rank pretty low
on some of the other components like
unemployment insurance taxes and a bit
thank you very much thank you okay uh
recognize Greg Moore from Americans for
prosperities
thank you madam chair members of the
committee I appreciate the opportunity
to speak here today for the record my
name is Greg Moore I am the state
director with Americans for Prosperity
here in New Hampshire and a lot of what
I would have said has already been said
so I'll say ditto to what uh some of the
folks earlier before me said in the
interest of time uh I know it's not
going to be snowing tonight but you know
that still gives you a chance to get
home and probably finish some of the
shoveling you might have missed out on
uh but I will say I will say that that
there is a two points first of all
uh I've come across a number of the
folks who have left the state as a
result of this interest in dividends tax
I know that the chair and the ranking
member member former representative Will
Smith he's a great example of somebody
who was a New Hampshire resident
and it is now Florida resident but he's
not really a Floridian because he still
Spends His summers in Newcastle but
because he lives more than six months in
Florida he avoids paying this interest
in dividends tax but what we lose uh by
having him do that is we lose the
opportunity to have him in uh spending
instead of eight months here spending
five months here and moreover
Dan not Dan although Dan there was a Dan
involved here but uh will was part of an
Angel Investment Group uh one of his one
of his colleagues and that was
representative McGuire uh but once once
will move to Florida
he stopped being part of the Angel
Investment Group that angel Investment
Group mostly invests in new
hampshire-based small businesses around
funding
um for a lot of groups to get them off
the ground
he's not the he's not the only one who
who's done this uh we've I've lost
frankly a couple of Fairly sizable
donors one of whom moved to Tennessee
just uprooted not not moved six months
of the year
to another state but actually uprooted
to Tennessee over this about three years
ago I wish I could have told him just
wait on hold on a few more years we
might be able to fix this but when we
lose these folks we lose people who are
big economic engines this particular
person was very big in real estate
investment now the good news is with our
with our real estate economy there's not
no real lack of real estate investment
in New Hampshire but having one more
person who's locally based as opposed to
one of these International Realty
investment trusts I think is something
that would have been value for our
valuable for our economy the second
thing I would say and try to keep this
as short as possible is I'd encourage
you to take a look at the work on this
based on by the beacon Center in
Tennessee the beacon Center in Tennessee
has done some time looking at the actual
overall economic impact as well as the
net impact for tax revenues on the
elimination of what they refer to as the
hall income tax what we call our IND tax
but if you go to the beacon Center's
website and just and just look up Hall
income tax don't don't type interest and
dividends type in Hall income tax you'll
get some great research in that space so
I'd encourage you to take a look at that
because because they've already done
what this bill proposes to do so
um always good to see what other states
the results other states have had when
you're considering policy before the
state so with that I'll close it because
I don't want to retread old ground
representative Olney has a question yeah
could you tell me is that the only state
that has looked at the issue of on our
wealthy investors in your state
investing actively or are they investing
uh through mutual mutual funds and ex
and IRAs and such thanks for the
question uh one of the
one of the areas but this has become a
really hot uh topic not necessarily
because of Tennessee and a whole income
tax but because of federal tax policy
and assault deduction a lot of these
issues have have uh risen up because
because a lot of States particularly in
New York New Jersey in particular in
Connecticut are three that have looked
closely into the salt because they have
a lot of high net worth
High a lot of high net worth people who
as a result of the salt are seeing
substantial federal income tax returns
and they're looking for ways to do that
I have to be candid I haven't spent too
much time looking into that
um but I know I know that that that is
something that's taken place within
those three states and you and you might
want to look to those three states as to
how they're approaching this but it's
again that's as relate to federal tax
all right we'll recognize Dennis Hall
chair
um I would just like to make a couple of
points I promise to keep it brief
we at ATR believe the taxes should be
flatter simpler more visible and lower
than they are today and this bill would
accelerate the process to accomplish all
all four of these goals at once
um
an under discussed aspect of the
interest in dividends tax is that
dividends can be considered a form of
double taxation most Dividends are paid
by larger corporations who have
shareholders and are also subject to the
business profits tax these profits are
taxed at the entity level and then taxed
again when they're paid out to
individuals in the form of dividends so
essentially the state is taxing these
these profits more than once so by
passing this bill New Hampshire can
limit the taxation of corporate profits
to the corporations themselves and leave
individuals free to save and invest and
to that point in a high inflationary
environment getting rid of this tax
should be a top priority even when
inflation is low there are limited
options for the middle class and even
the low class to protect the value of
their hard-earned dollars they have to
buy bonds or they have to buy stocks or
they have to find some way to generate a
return on investment and this tax is
nothing more than
um a five percent or however much the
rate will be next year in the year
Beyond on those returns that they're
relying hang on to make ends meet and
most Americans are foregoing this sort
of long-term investment they're not
saving they're racking up credit card
bills to get by and hoping for the best
that inflation drops again and hopefully
it will but this bill would leave
residents free to keep a hundred percent
of their earnings on saving an
investment and it would incentivize
fiscal responsibility both in the short
term and the long term maximizing the
ability of New Hampshire rights to be
inflation
and finally I'll just say the no income
tax state movement is large and growing
and it's best for New Hampshire to join
this group without restrictions as soon
as possible four states will eliminate
their income tax over the next several
years 11 states have passed legislation
to cut their income tax rate in 2022
alone 23 States now have a flat tax
including Idaho and legislators are
considering bringing down this rate in a
Litany of different states in 2023 and
as I mentioned before the census data
and pretty much any studies that you'll
look at show that Americans are moving
to these states part of it might be the
warmth I grew up in Florida and it's
absolutely gorgeous I wish I was there
right now but a large part of this is
also have to do with their with their
with their business friendly environment
and friendly tax environment for
individuals and families so with that I
will leave it there and any questions
are appreciated thank you very much
questions
thank you very much thank you
okay our last two pink cards are from
the dra
foreign
tax policy Council for Department of
Revenue
good afternoon Lauren O'Sullivan from
the Department of Revenue
I just handed out a fiscal note quick
guide in regards to the fiscal note that
we prepared for the house bill 100 and
the department does not have a position
on this bill and we're here to address
representative Schoenberg
thank you madam chair
and thank you dra representatives for
taking this question
going back to my question to
representative McGuire
does the LLC
pay any taxes
of money that's invested into them or
bet BPT any
yes so uh New Hampshire taxes the
business taxes for New Hampshire taxes
on an entity level basis so that's
different from the federal taxation
where it passes on a pass-through basis
um so the LLC
Kevin conducting business activities in
New Hampshire will be subject to the
okay uh representative homie
thank you um
just I've got another question a bigger
one but on following up on this one we
have something in the law that exempts
the LLCs from paying
attacks do you know what it is
business taxes well I indeed no I and D
oh yes
uh for Indy taxes uh
the LLC will be subject to the Indy tax
if it's not represented by transferable
shares
right
thank you
oh
and and if if I could on that one
sorry on
I know a guy in my community that when I
talk to them about business which is a
while back now he had 25 llc's
about a third of them I think were
were convenience stores attached to gas
stations
do you combine
an LL guys different llc's when they're
the same kind of business or in general
or what do you do
about about that so from a business tax
perspective we'll
we will consider if all those LLCs are
unitary or not and if they're unitary
and if uh the one of the aspects of
filing a combined return is that the
business entities also conduct business
within and without New Hampshire if the
business activity if the business entity
is not doing meaning that uh requirement
then each of the business entities will
have to file its own uh business return
from an IND perspective uh each LLC will
be looked at
individually whether that LLC is
represented by transferable shares or
non-transferable shares
thank you I do have a different question
but maybe if there's someone else
let's just see if anyone else has a
question
seeing none go ahead
I'm not sure whether I should be talking
with you or the Comptroller but on I
want someone maybe lbao someone besides
me to
look at the percentage growth rates of
in New Hampshire from say 2004 because
before that we just finished changing
the tax rates on to
relative to
the percentage growth in the country and
because we have this
very variable understanding of whether
we are behind the eight ball when we're
coming out of recessions
in in New Hampshire and believe me in
the Great Recession we we were three
two years maybe but I think it was three
uh and I believe it was that way in 10
which was pretty small as well so it was
just a blip
uh representative if you're referring I
mean I don't mean 10 I mean
um two thousand
representative you're referring to a GDP
New Hampshire GDP growth rate oh we we
don't have that data yeah no I'm talking
about the revenues oh Revenue growth
and I was brought up here over 26 years
by we're always late coming out of
recessions but we were late going into
them so I want to see what the evidence
is and we can't really get comparable
evidence before
2004 because we changed a lot of taxes
in 1999 to 2001.
we do have uh Revenue data statistics uh
or uh for the past 10 years we actually
compiled that I believe we do have that
right yeah yeah so in in the uh in the
upcoming house race it means
presentation uh there would be a
uh
one of the slides would have the uh a
10-year Revenue Trend yeah historical
if I could
follow up this only goes back to 2012
which was the for Most states the end of
the recession
and or 11 even what's what's the
earliest year that you're looking to oh
four oh four okay
it could be O2 I I can't remember how
long it it took for us to stabilize
after we changed all of the rates of
everything and added a few taxes
are you looking at all tax all taxes
against GDP is that uh no looking at all
taxes uh in New Hampshire versus in New
it's it must be in somebody's statistics
somewhere
we probably will not have the tax
revenue data for other states
seems to have an idea and I would also
just submit be clear we're not all on
the same fiscal year I know
representative orrs
thank you madam chair this is just some
thoughts uh representative on me what
wasn't the like the Great Recession 2008
wouldn't it make sense to go to 2008 I'm
not saying I'm just thinking if we
change the tax code in 99 to 2001 we
would have a good Runway of information
coming into the 2008 recession I maybe
that would be better data
yeah well we would get better data if we
kept it at 0.7 or 08. so yeah maybe 08
is when we first started to see it in
our revenues right okay and and if I can
ask a question to representative of all
me your first question seemed like a
really good question but I couldn't hear
the answer and I was wondering if we
could repeat that sequence because I'm
hoping to learn something yeah about the
LLCs
whether whether the llc's what the llc's
are exempt from in in business taxes and
interest in dividends taxes and I
believe what you said is that for
business taxes on they are not exempt
in any way but in the
interest in dividends tax
they are exempt if they
have don't have transferable shares or
do have transferable shares so um
the uh Partnerships and llc's that are
not represented by transferable shares
EF if I could ask yeah I'm sorry could
you repeat that I can't hear you
Partnerships and LLCs that are shared
that are represented by uh represented
by not represented by transferable
shares are subject to the IND
R yes
thank you
all right this is obviously confusing we
will come back to these topics again
thank you so much for being here so
we'll let's I don't have any other pink
cards
is there anyone else would like to speak
seeing none we will close the public